l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement
mes chers collègues je vous rappelle que
nos travaux se déroulent sous le regard
de nos concitoyens j'ai reçus à l'issue
de notre précédente séance de questions
au gouvernement de nombreux messages
d'émotion face au tumulte qui perturbe
parfois le déroulement des séances de
questions au gouvernement
ceci affecte gravement l'image de notre
assemblée je vous invite donc
solennellement à écouter les orateurs en
vous abstenant de tout exclamations ou
interpellation bruyante
la parole est à madame florence lasserre
je vous remercie monsieur le président
le 5 juillet un homme
filimon guillaud a été victime d'une
agression d'une extrême violence
il était chauffeur de bus il est décédé
chez moi à bayonne
cet après midi devant la représentation
nationale
je tiens à lui rendre hommage
je tiens aussi à exprimer de manière
sincère et profonde
toute ma compassion à l'égard de son
épouse de ses trois filles de ses
collègues pour qu'ils les jours et les
nuits sont si difficiles
monsieur le président ma question pour s
adresser à monsieur le premier ministre
à monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur à
monsieur le ministre de la justice des
transports où monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale dans le drame qui
s'est noué au pays basque il y a bien
entendu à première vue un problème de
sécurité dans les transports auxquels
nous devrons apporter des réponses mais
j'y vois un problème bien plus profond
il y a dans notre société des personnes
qui ne respectent plus les règles de la
république
il est en france aujourd'hui des
personnes qui font de ces violations de
notre pacte républicain un mode de vie
la devise notre pays
liberté égalité fraternité s'appuie sur
des valeurs socle forte qui ne devrait
plus être abîmées alors mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
que comptez vous faire pour les imposer
à celles et ceux qui chaque jour s'en
détournent
et pour redonner espoir et confiance aux
françaises et aux français qu'ils ont
chez juillet au corps je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés madame
la députée florence lasserre je veux au
nom du premier ministre au nom du
gouvernement vous dire également toute
l'indignation qui est celle de la
république devant cet acte odieux qui
renvoyait une famille
j'ai rencontré vous le savez madame au
bio et ses trois filles et monsieur
mauguio a quitté sa famille le matin
fier de son travail pour mourir dans des
conditions particulièrement atroces
alors qu'il avait simplement demandé à
des gens qui étaient montés dans un bus
de payer leurs tickets de porter un
masque
ce n'est pas simplement lui qui a été
attaqué c'est l'autorité
et si finalement un peu de nous mêmes
c'est un peu de la république qui a été
blessé tué par ces actes horribles et
qui ont été je dois le dire très
rapidement appréhendé par la police
nationale qui a fait un travail
extraordinaire vous le savez bien
dès le lendemain grâce à la
vidéoprotection du bus installé cinq
interpellations ont eu lieu
quatre personnes ont pu être présentés
et sous l'autorité de monsieur le
procureur de la république et des
magistrats ont été écroués et mis en
examen cet acte particulièrement
horrible doit pas simplement raisonnée
pour le pays basque
madame la députée il doit résonner pour
toute la république depuis désormais
trop longtemps les conducteurs de bus
les professeurs des écoles
les médecins les pompiers encore riera
est en cours je me suis rendu mais aussi
des policiers et les gendarmes
parce qu'ils portent l'autorité parce
qu'il porte l'uniforme de la république
sont insultés sont blessés et parfois
perdre leur vie et je veux ici leur
rendre hommage
une nouvelle fois
j'aurai l'occasion
j'aurai l'occasion avec le ministre des
transports dans les prochains jours de
travail et encore plus avec vous et avec
les sociétés de transport pour renforcer
la sécurité évidemment des conducteurs
de bus merci monsieur le ministre la
parole à monsieur alexis corbière
monsieur le premier ministre hier vous
avez martelé que je cite c'est la france
des territoires qui détient les clés du
sursaut collectif
il faudrait une nouvelle étape de
décentralisation dites-vous qui sera
marquée par je vous cite à nouveau un
droit à la différenciation entre les
territoires
nous ne sommes pas d'accord car votre
droit à la différenciation c'est la
différenciation des droits al'inverse
l'exigence qui monte dans notre pays et
celle d'égalité des droits
ces différenciations entraîne
généralement une dislocation de la
nation française c'est une france des
régions se faisant concurrence entre
elles encouragent et généralement par
l'union européenne épargnez nous les
fadaises pour soi-disant rapprocher les
citoyens des prises de décision on a vu
le résultat plus personne n'y comprend
rien l'abstention ne cesse de progresser
même aux élections locales la crise de
nos institutions ne sera pas résolu par
l'aggravation de la décentralisation
n'est pas une refondation républicaine
issue d'une assemblée constituante
pas de faux débat la promesse d'égalité
que porte notre histoire républicaine
n'a jamais signifié l'uniformité
mais elle est conditionnée par un état
fort planificateur garant de l'intérêt
général
certains n'ont pas un lent retour vers
l'ancien régime ou l'exaltation des
particularismes locaux sont relooké en
territoire je suis élue de
seine-saint-denis un département qui
subit depuis des années la
différenciation des droits
chez nous toutes et différenciation dans
nos collèges les professeurs sont plus
mal remplacé dans nos hôpitaux
les lits sont plus surchargées notre
police dans moins de moyens de
travailler tout est sous doté en
comparaison avec les autres départements
et en particulier notre voisin parisien
c'est notamment la source d'une
surmortalité terrible que nous avons
connu pendant la crise du coup
monsieur premier nice caen entendrez
vous notre exigence de justice d'égalité
et certainement pas de droit la
différenciation cette exigence est celle
des habitants de mon département
c'est aussi je le crois c'est de la
grande majorité de nos concitoyens je
vous remercie
la parole est à mme jacqueline gourault
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
monsieur le député alexis corbière
je vous cherche du regard pardon voilà
j'ai bien entendu ce que vous venez de
dire est effectivement je vous confirme
comme l'a dit le premier ministre hier
et comme il l'a réitéré ce matin au
sénat qu'il y aura une nouvelle étape de
décentralisation et il y aura un projet
de loi de décentralisation de
différenciation et également de
déconcentration
je crois que vous avez analysé le mot
différenciation comme différent de celui
que nous prônons en effet que ça citic
de faire pour la différenciation
il s'agit de répondre aux besoins des
spécificités des territoires
est ce que vous croyez qu aujourd'hui et
c'est souvent répété qu'il y a des
territoires très fait vous partez vous
parlez de quartier de ville et de votre
département
il y a aussi des territoires ruraux qui
sont très isolés qui ont peu de moyens
donc la différenciation c'est être
capable de répondre à la spécificité des
territoires et à l'état des territoires
pour combler les fractures territoriales
et les fractures qui sont derrière
sociale donc la différenciation
l'expérimentation nous avons déposé un
projet de loi organique pour développer
l'expérimentation qui doit nous
permettent d'arriver à la
différenciation pour simplifier l'accès
à l'expérimentation et pour essayer de
couper cet aspect binaire qui fait qu'on
est obligé détendre sur tout sur tout le
territoire
une expérimentation qui est fait
les territoires je crois que c'est une
bonne démarche pour répondre aux
fractures territoriales qui existe sur
notre territoire et la différenciation
monsieur le député c'est une manière de
répondre à l'égalité à l'équité des
citoyens merci mme la ministre
la parole est à madame béatrice descamps
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé monsieur le
ministre
moins de trois gynécologues médicaux en
france pour cent mille femmes 65%
d'entre eux ont plus de 60 ans et
approchent de l'âge de la retraite 13
départements français ne possède pas de
gynécologues médicaux dans certains
territoires
il faut parfois attendre plus d'un an
pour obtenir un rendez vous telle est la
réalité pour la santé des femmes en
france
il en va de même pour les gynécologues
obstétrique en témoignent les fermetures
de maternités pour cause de
sous-effectif de médecins l'acca indique
par ailleurs que 61 % des nouveaux cas
de cancer chez la femme sont des cancers
gynécologiques
derrière ces chiffres se dévoile aux
torts de femmes de tout âge n'ayant pas
ou plus de suivi de prévention de
dépistage précoce pour les accompagner
tout au long de leur vie
rappelons nous que cette spécialité de
gynécologie médicale avait été supprimé
en 87
si depuis la recréation du diplôme en
2003 le saviez le nombre de postes da
terme ouvert en gynécologie médicale a
connu une augmentation sensible ne va
pas en 2003 à 82 pas en 2019 aujourd'hui
encore dans notre pays
moins de mille gynécologues médicaux
pour 30 millions de femmes je le répète
monsieur le ministre en période
d'épreuves classantes nationales mais
surtout pour toutes les prochaines
années à venir quelles mesures concrètes
allez vous prendre pour combler ce
gouffre et s'atteler sérieusement à la
formation en nombre de gynécologues
médicaux
il s'agit d'un enjeu de santé publique
majeur
il s'agit de la vie des femmes et des
jeunes filles françaises je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé madame madame
la députée battait quand je vous
remercie pour votre question qui est une
récuse une question récurrente parce que
légitime au sein de cet hémicycle et qui
consiste à savoir comment est organisé
aujourd'hui l'accès aux soins
gynécologiques pour les femmes de notre
pays
c'est une longue histoire que l'histoire
de la gynécologie médicale en france
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre d'années
je devais alors être moi-même interne il
était question que la discipline
disparaissent au profit des gynécos
obstétriciens je crois qu'à l'époque sur
20 formé il y en avait un certain nombre
qui partait en endocrinologie médical de
sorte qu'il n'y avait que six ou sept
gynécologues médicaux qui s'installait
dans le pays
la filière n'a jamais été supprimée
suite à une mobilisation des
gynécologues médical notamment et d'un
certain nombre de français et de
françaises
de sorte que comme vous l'avez rappelé
ce nombre n'a cessé d'augmenter année
après année nous étions à 64 et
gynécologues médicaux fort mais en 2017
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 81,2 dans un
même temps le nombre de gynécologues
obstétriciens a également augmenté de
sorte que le nombre de gynécologues
au total en formation a triplé entre
2012 et 2019
vous avez raison de souligner qu'entre
le moment où on prend une décision
d'augmentation d'une filière de
formation et le moment nous avons
suffisamment de professionnels sur le
terrain il va s'écouler du temps
néanmoins madame madame l'adse notre
imam députés un certain nombre de
dispositions existent pour renforcer
l'accès aux soins gynécologiques pour
les femmes de notre pays notamment les
médecins généralistes qui pour un grand
nombre d'entre eux sont formés à
l'exercice du frottis de l'examen
gynécologique médical est également les
maillots titien ce qu'on appelle les
sages femmes qui sont habilités à suivre
non seulement des femmes enceintes mais
également des femmes qui ne sont pas
enceintes dans le dans le cadre d'un
suivi régulier de la santé de la femme
et enfin madame la députée vous parler à
juste titre des cancers gynécologiques
qui tue dans notre pays est l'une des
premières causes de mortalité de la
femme jeune c'est le cancer du col de
l'utérus
il se trouve qu'au delà du dépistage qui
est fondamental il existe aussi un moyen
de prévention de ce cancer à savoir la
taxe
à sion contre le papillomavirus c'est un
débat parlementaire qu'il nous faudra
avoir dans les mois ou les années à
venir parce que c'est une manière de
protéger les jeunes femmes un certain
nombre de pays ont pris la décision
courageuse d'aller vers une
systématisation de l'actionnaire sims en
attendant les applaudissements jeudi qui
est peut-être un chemin à parcourir dans
notre pays merci merci monsieur le
ministre
madame le député merci monsieur le
ministre pour votre réponse vous l'avez
compris vous l'avez dit les urgent
aujourd'hui en france poursuivre une
réflexion concernant la prise en charge
de la santé des femmes
une réflexion dans une approche
pluridisciplinaire peut-être comme
l'avait annoncé votre prédécesseur
merci mono débuté la parole est un
monsieur jean pierre door
merci merci monsieur le président la
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
le corona virus continue de progresser
dans le monde et la france n'est pas à
l'abri d'une reprise épidémique les
manifestations récentes à paris à nice
et lors d'une rave party à caudal nevers
à côté de ma circonscription réunissant
cinq mille personnes sans précaution
relève de la provocation et je le dis de
la débilité sociale monsieur le premier
ministre
l'académie nationale de médecine la
tribune signée par une quinzaine
d'éminents médecins préconisent le port
du masque dans les lieux publics
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
eu connaissance de mon rapport
parlementaire sur les risques
épidémiques qui prônait le port
obligatoire du masque pour limiter la
paralysie de l'état
nos voisins européens l'ont déjà adopté
alors quand il était inutile en mars il
devient utile aujourd'hui d'après la
déclaration du président de la
république
le groupe des républicains vous demande
monsieur le premier ministre de ne plus
tarder de ne plus tergiverser sur
l'obligation du masque dans les milieux
clos il y a urgence sans délai que le
port du masque doit être imposée dès ce
week-end pour ne pas voir repartir des
manifestations à hauts risques
et en même temps nous vous demanderons
d'accélérer évidemment le dépistage des
des tests par les tests car nous sommes
loin du compte des 700 milles par
semaine je vous remercie
merci monsieur les buts et la parole est
à monsieur olivier véran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député jean-pierre door d'abord vous
dire que je partage votre agacement face
aux images que nous avons constatées
dans la nièvre avec une rave party fasse
de façon générale à toutes les
situations qui regroupe des centaines
des milliers de personnes sans aucune
protection sans aucune distanciation
social et qui met en péril toute la
stratégie française en matière de lutte
contre le coronavirus la ministre
déléguée à la citoyenneté marlène
schiappa s'est rendu d'ailleurs sur site
et nous avons distribué masque gel
hydroalcoolique bon cnam pour avoir des
tests on sait que la situation était
extrêmement délicate et je vous remercie
de nous donner l'occasion de revenir sur
ce point sur le sujet du port du masque
systématiser voir demain et demain
obligatoire dans les lieux clos et bien
il ya un décret qui est en cours de
finalisation monsieur le député d'ici à
lundi ou mardi
le port du masque devra être généralisé
mais vous savez monsieur monsieur le
député avant même un décret la vigilance
l'esprit de responsabilité et de
citoyenneté des français ils ne
nécessitent pas de décret genou
encourager j'invite l'ensemble des
français a sans délai sans attendre la
parution d'un décret et sans que
l'obligation s'est inscrite dans le
marbre à porter un masque dans tous les
lieux clos quels qu'ils soient et
lorsqu'ils sont regroupés encore
davantage tout en rappelant monsieur le
député tout en rappelant que porter un
masque ne protège pas en soi si l'on ne
fait pas attention notamment au passage
par les mains et qu'il faut conserver de
la distanciation social qu'il faut se
laver les mains il faut utiliser du gel
hydroalcoolique
il faut changer son masque le porter
correctement tout cela et d'un travail
et de vigilance de tous les instants
absolument nécessaire surtout à l'heure
où un certain nombre d'indicateurs
tendent à montrer que non seulement
l'épidémie n'est pas père
né mais qui vient des signes de
résurgence saïda du virus je pense
notamment à la mayenne ou à certains
hôpitaux parisiens j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire ce matin
enfin monsieur le député s'agissant des
tests nous allons atteindre la barre des
400 mille tests nous sommes capables
d'en faire bien davantage et même un
million par semaine s'il le fallait
et oui messieurs les députés et
laboratoires sont aptes à le faire
maintenant nous invitons les français
qui hésitent à se faire tester à le
faire et le présent de la république m
la parole est à madame florence
morlighem monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame elisabeth
bornes ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de l'insertion la crise sanitaire
exceptionnelle que nous traversons
aurait dans les prochains mois de fortes
répercussions économiques et sociales
cette première urgence soulignée par le
président de la république lors de son
interview du 14 juillet et par le
premier ministre lors de sa déclaration
de politique générale devant l'assemblée
nationale hier concerne l'avenir de nos
jeunes un plan pour la jeunesse sera
discuté avec les partenaires sociaux dès
ce vendredi car rien ne se fera sans
dialogue social il ya une véritable
urgence sociale
sept cent mille jeunes arrivent dès
septembre 2020 sur le marché du travail
il faut aller chercher les jeunes les
plus éloignés de l'emploi
beaucoup a été fait depuis juin 2010 est
par le gouvernement soutenu par la
majorité présidentielle avec par exemple
le développement de l'apprentissage
mais la crise exceptionnelle que nous
connaissons nous oblige à accélérer à
créer des mécanismes nouveaux en
particulier pour les jeunes qui n'ont pu
trouver une entreprise qui leur signe
leur coupe tra d'apprentissage ou
d'alternance
le service civique est un très bel outil
et d'engagement citoyen à destination
des jeunes désireux de s'impliquer dans
la vie de la cité
le service civique fonctionne il y
actuellement 140 mille jeunes en contrat
de service civique et il faut développer
la mesure pour aller chercher les
éloignés de l'emploi il faut tout faire
pour que les jeunes puissent avoir accès
au marché du travail ce qui passe par
une amplification de l'action menée
depuis juin 2010 est sur la réduction
des coûts du travail pour les jeunes de
moins de 25 ans mais les situations des
jeunes sont hétérogènes
il faut les appréhender dans toute leur
complexité
ainsi certains jeunes n'auront pas de
perspectives d'embauché à court terme
il faut donc leur permettre de
poursuivre leurs études avec un
accompagnement social
pouvez vous madame la ministre nous
présenter les principaux axes de la
politique la parole comme dame elizabeth
bornes ministre du travail de l'emploi
et de l'insertion
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
florence morlighem alors vous avez
raison notre urgence c'est la jeunesse
je connais votre engagement sur ces
sujets dans le département du nord
nous avons demandé des sacrifices
importants à nos jeunes pendant le
confinement pour protéger nos aînés et
nous devons maintenant leur renvoyer
l'ascenseur
alors notre objectif est simple aucun
jeunes sans solution avec des réponses
adaptées à chaque situation
pour les jeunes qui sont le plus proches
de l'emploi nous allons faciliter les
embauches avec une compensation de
charges à hauteur de 4000 euros par an
pour une embauche en cdi
ou sur un cdd suffisamment long pour
ceux qui veulent s'engager dans
l'apprentissage ou les contrats de
professionnalisation nous allons
continuer à mettre le paquet avec une
prime de 5000 euros pour les moins de 18
ans 8000 euros pour les plus de 18 ans
pour les plus éloignés de l'emploi nous
allons créer 300 milles parcourus au
contrat d'insertion supplémentaires nous
allons nous appuyer sur les dispositifs
existants travailler avec les acteurs
locaux pour que ce soit des véritable
tremplin vers un emploi durable
et puis enfin nous allons créer cent
mille service civique supplémentaire
pour ceux qui veulent s'engager dans une
mission utile à la société
en attendant que la conjoncture
s'améliore alors ce plan effectivement
sera discuté avec les partenaires
sociaux demain conformément à la méthode
qui vous a été exposé par le premier
ministre hier notre jeunesse ne peut
attendre la réponse que nous allons
bâtir avec les partenaires sociaux avec
les territoires sera à la hauteur
merci madame la ministre
la parole quand monsieur joaquim pueyo
merci merci monsieur le président il
s'agit de ma dernière question car je
m'apprête à quitter mes fonctions de
député suite à mon élection en tant que
maire d'alençon et président de la
communauté urbaine d'alençon
je tiens à remercier mes collègues de
tous les groupes politiques et des non
inscrits avec qui j'ai noué des
relations cordiales et humaine très
enrichissante dans le cadre de mon
travail de parlementaire
merci monsieur le premier ministre il ya
tout juste cinq ans le président a
république annoncé un confinement strict
pour faire face à l'épidémie du comique
19 sur l'ensemble des territoires
les élus locaux administrations locales
ont été en première ligne pour répondre
aux préoccupations attentes et besoins
des habitants
nous avons à nouveau constater
l'importance des différents échelons
décentralisée même si je découpage
territorial peut parfois créer des
lenteurs et lourdeurs dans la prise de
décision il reste garant d'un dialogue
avec l'ensemble des acteurs présents au
plus près des préoccupations des
français
si la décision nationale permis une
cohérence son application nécessite très
souvent des adaptations aux
particularités locales
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
évoqué de nombreuses fois les
territoires lors de votre discours de
politique générale et non scié des
mesures qui devraient être prises afin
de lier nouvel acte de décentralisation
et plan de relance ce second point doit
rester au coeur de nos préoccupations
afin de soutenir notre économie et
maintenir le pouvoir d'achat des
français notamment celui des preuves des
plus fragiles si les collectivités
locales sont en première ligne
il faut leur donner les moyens d'agir le
texte de la future réforme devra être
ambitieux et faire évoluer avec
précision la décentralisation la
répartition des compétences et les modes
d'élection mais tout cela n'a aucun
effet si on donne pas aux collectivités
les moyens humains et financiers de
remplir leur mission
un nouvel acte de décentralisation et de
déconcentration ambition sera le seul à
même de répondre à la volonté exprimée
par nos concitoyens de participer à la
définition des politiques publiques sur
premier ministe pouvez-vous nous exposer
les prérogatives et moyens qui seront
données aux collectivités locales dans
le cadre de ce nouvel acte de
décentralisation afin de répondre aux
défis de demain je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et avec nos
félicitations tous nos voeux de succès
dans l'exercice du mandat qui vient de
vous être confiées à la tête de la ville
d'alençon
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
un monsieur le député joaquim pueyo
je tiens tout d'abord à vous féliciter
pour votre élection à la mairie
d'alençon et à la communauté urbaine
d'alençon vraiment toutes mes
félicitations vous avez fait le choix
après deux mandats nationaux
vous avez fait le choix de devenir maire
de la commune
vos citoyens vous ont élus choisis et
bien sûr je sais pour avoir été moi même
mère pendant de longues années qu'elle
est comment dire la richesse de cette
mission et je connais votre sens du
dialogue et du service public je suis
sûr que vos concitoyens et bien en
seront ravis
je voulais bien sûr vous assurer que ce
que vous avez dit bien sûr va être mis
en forme le premier ministre encore une
fois annoncé une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation et bien sûr
naturellement il a dit qu'il y aurait ce
matin au sénat un nouveau texte
naturellement nous savons que la
décentralisation s'accompagne toujours
des moyens ses mamelles inscrit dans la
constitution et nous allons aussi je les
dis et je le redis discuter de
différenciation avec ce projet de loi
que nous avons déposés pour jets de loi
organique qui va passer au conseil des
ministres le 29 juillet donc je voulais
vous dire monsieur le député que
naturellement nous avons encore beaucoup
à travailler ensemble car en tant que
maire en tant que président de la
communauté urbaine
vous aurez votre mot à dire dans tout
cela et je serai ravi de me rendre à
alençon pour discuter avec vous de tout
cet avenir de la décentralisation et de
l'avenir des collectivités territoriales
qui comme vous l'avez dit sont toutes
utiles elles ont toutes la vocation à
servir pour nos concitoyens
merci madame la ministre la parole est à
madame sabine thilay merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre demain et après demain
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
l'union européenne se retrouveront à
bruxelles pour concrétiser le plan de
relance et notre budget commun pour les
sept années à venir
deux jours deux jours pour s'accorder
sur le sauvetage de l'europe sur la
table une solution à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
nous nous apprêtons à faire un saut
qualitatif plus que jamais nécessaire un
fonds de 750 milliards d'euros sera levé
au nom de tous certes ce n'est pas la
première fois que la commission
européenne emprunte sur les marchés
mais cette fois ci nous parlons de 500
milliards de subventions distribuées via
les programmes budgétaires de l'union
en outre la commission propose un
remboursement en proportion des
contributions les états membres au
budget et non en fonction des sommes
utilisées par chacun peut-être à un cap
historique mais les modalités
d'allocutions d'allocations les fonds et
le mode de remboursement divise les
états or nous le savons tous mettra
d'accord 27 états membres
sans faire preuve de compromis n'est
presque pas possible d'autant que le
plan de relance et cadre financier
pluriannuel sont débattus conjointement
multipliant ainsi les lives y ait des
négociations et les marchandages
possible comment s'assurer que l'intérêt
collectif c'est dessine en accord avec
les ambitions françaises
je pense ici aux projets de défense
européenne qui nécessite un financement
adéquat ou rénover le mans de la pac
mais aussi là l'ambition de lier l'accès
aux financements au respect des règles
de l'état de droit doit il faudrait
également traité de la participation de
chacun ses budgets la philosophie du
juste retour des rabais
on ne trouve plus d'écho en cette
période de crise ainsi monsieur le
premier ministre pouvez vous nous
éclairer sur les impératifs français et
jusqu'où vous serez prêt à aller pour
les défendre quelles synergies
envisagées vous entre le premier plan de
relance français annoncée hier est celui
de l'europe négocier demain et quelle
place nous lire si madame le député
merci madame barbara pompili ministre de
la transition écologique
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires européennes cher sabine thilay
c'est un moment d'une extrême importance
qui va se tenir entre les 27 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union
européenne demain et après-demain d'une
extrême importance parce que comme vous
l'avez rappelé un accord devra être
trouvé sur le plan de relance européen
comme sur le budget de l'union
européenne
vous l'avez rappelé également il s'agit
d'une révolution visant à mettre en
oeuvre concrètement un mécanisme de
solidarité entre états membres pour
faire face aux conséquences de la crise
du coc vie de 19 grâce à un an 1
l'emprunt en conjointe et une dette
conjointe mais n'a président depuis son
discours de la sorbonne en septembre
2010 est le président de la république a
eu l'occasion de rappeler l'importance
qu'il attachait à la fois à la défense
européenne comme à la politique agricole
commune
ces éléments sont très importants dans
le budget européen ils feront partie des
priorités portée par la france dans les
négociations à venir
je veux évidemment dire un mot sur
l'écologie vous avez mentionné en fin de
votre question parce qu'il est une
préoccupation majeure de nos concitoyens
comme vous le savez la mise en oeuvre du
green deal du pacte vert doit être au
coeur de la relance
cela signifie notamment que les nouveaux
instruments financiers sur le fond de
relancer le fond de résidence ainsi que
le fonds de transition juste doivent
être mis en oeuvre avec en ligne de mire
l'objectif de neutralité carbone en 2050
et l'objectif intermédiaire de réduction
de gaz à effet de serre en 2030 avec
insu un sujet un souci de justice
sociale et territoriale
cela signifie également et la france le
porte que nous puissions mettre en
oeuvre très concrètement des éco
conditionnalité à la mobilisation de ses
financements conformément notamment au
principe du doubs notre arme pour la
protection du climat et de la
biodiversité et cela veut dire enfin
qu'une part substantielle de 30 % du
budget global cadre financier
pluriannuel et plan de relance puissent
être fléché vers l'objectif climatique
et environnementale ce sont les
priorités qui seront défendues par le
président de la république et que je
défendrai dans les prochaines semaines
auprès de mes collègues européens avec
lesquels j'ai déjà commencé à échanger
jour merci merci madame la ministre
la parole est à monsieur eric pauget
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
en période de crise le temps est notre
ennemi hier vous avez évoqué l'arrivée
d'une crise économique majeure en france
trop tard cette crise est déjà là depuis
longtemps le manque d'anticipation face
aux urgences d'hyères conduit aux crises
d'aujourd'hui et avec elle c'est
l'habitude du retard qui s'installe
malheureusement dans notre pays
retard déjà face à l'urgence sanitaire
masque test gel respirateur quel manque
d'anticipation
quand gouverner c'est prévoir les crises
se multiplient et se succèdent et la
gestion chaotique du gouvernement a des
conséquences catastrophiques
conséquences sanitaires d'abord
économique ensuite et social désormais
monsieur le premier ministre nous ne
pouvons plus perdre de temps
la relance n'est pas seulement
indispensable
elle est urgentissime pour de nombreuses
entreprises françaises il sera trop tard
en septembre
chaque jour qui passe notre économie
dégradé fragilise un peu plus nos
entreprises nos emplois et notre société
tout entière
que de temps perdu alors que nos voisins
allemands et anglais ont déjà amorcé
leur relance
quand vous préférez attendre encore deux
mois de plus que de temps perdu alors
que les députés les républicains vous en
proposer un plan de relance puissant
crédible et cohérent dès le mois de mai
nous nourrir nous nous nous réclamons
une relance économique pour accélérer la
croissance
pragmatique et en avance quand nous vous
proposions d'abaisser la tva à 5,5 dans
le secteur de l'hôtellerie la
restauration pragmatique et en avance
quand nous vous proposions de créer un
statut d'intermittent du tourisme pour
défendre l'activité de l'emploi et
particulièrement dans mon département
des alpes-maritimes où le tourisme
souffrent pragmatique et en avance
encore quand vous nous quand nous vous
proposions le 11 juin dernier de voter
l'exonération des charges sociales pour
l'embauché des jeunes
vous l'avez alors tout simplement
rejetés monsieur le premier ministre
attendre la rentrée de septembre c'est
faire le choix d'arriver encore une fois
trop tard l'urgence économique c'est
maintenant à quand le passage des
paroles aux actes
merci chers collègues le bol invité
madame agnès pannier une hache et
ministre de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
po j'ai bien au contraire je crois que
l'état a été au rendez vous de ses
responsabilités auprès des entreprises
et de l'économie
et je crois que c'est assez largement
reconnue par nos voisins européens et
par les entreprises qui sont présentes
dans plusieurs pays qui nous disent que
des dispositifs mis aussi rapidement en
oeuvre avec autant d'efficacité
il n'y a pas beaucoup de pays qui
peuvent s'en prévaloir l'état était au
rendez vous de ses responsabilités
auprès des salariés avec le chômage
partiel qui a permis à 40% de la
population salariée de passer le cap de
cette crise l'état a été au rendez vous
de ses responsabilités auprès des
indépendants avec le fonds de solidarité
auprès des entreprises
avec le prêt garanti par les par l'état
il est également d'ores et déjà la
manoeuvre pour la relance économique
je pense au plan tourisme qui vous tient
tant à coeur secteur si important et
nous sommes à la manoeuvre aujourd'hui
avec un plan inédit qui a été mise en
oeuvre à partir du 14 mai dernier
je pense également au plan aéronautique
au plan automobile au plan pour les
commerçants et les artisans 460
milliards d'euros au total au service de
notre économie
je crois que nous sommes d'ores et déjà
bien en avance pour redresser cette
économie alors oui oui nous anticipons
tout en traitant l'urgence lorsque nous
investissons au service de
l'aéronautique et de la r&d en
multipliant par quatre
nous regardons devant nous et ça s'est
d'ores et déjà dans les plans
oui nous anticipons les relocalisations
avec un milliard d'euros réinvesti sur
la chaîne de traction électrique dans
l'automobile et je pourrais multiplier
les exemples
mais nous ne confondons pas urgence et
précipitation c'est tout l'enjeu du plan
de relance de 100 milliards d'euros qui
sera au rendez vous dans le bon timing
pour continuer à approfondir cette
trajectoire de reconstruction que nous
avons dansé déjà largement entamé merci
la parole est à monsieur philippe
chalumeau merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des solidarités et
de la santé et le ségur de la santé
vient de se conclure ce lundi 13 juillet
par un accord historique et la
reconnaissance de la nation toute
entière à nos soignants célébré à
l'occasion du 14 juillet la méthode
employée en fait un accord historique
puisque ont un temps record est parvenu
à mener une très large concertation en
portant une attention réelle et sincère
au dialogue social avec l'ensemble des
métiers du soin afin d'aboutir à un
consensus avec les organisations
syndicales majoritaires
ça n'était pas acquis d'avancé et je
tiens à saluer votre engagement
personnel dans ce dialogue
cet accord est historique aussi par son
ampleur et son périmètre en agitant 8,1
milliards d'euros dans les ressources
humaines de nos hôpitaux vous actes et
des niveaux de revalorisation salariale
largement méritée mais jamais atteint il
concerne toutes celles et ceux qui font
vivre nos services de soins au quotidien
vous n'avez pas oublié non plus et je
vous en remercie particulièrement nos
jeunes étudiants en médecine qui sont
l'avenir de nos hôpitaux pour les
personnels médecin l'accord porte sur
une enveloppe globale de 450 millions
d'euros versée aux praticiens qui
s'engagent à ne travailler que dans les
opus les hôpitaux publics et sans
dépassement d'honoraires
toutes ces revalorisations était urgente
et indispensable et je suis heureux
qu'elle soit assortie d'une refonte des
grilles salariales de la fonction
publique hospitalière incluant une
évolution plus dynamique des carrières
enfin vous avez vous lu obtenu le
recrutement de 15000 soignants
supplémentaire pour soulager le soignant
très éprouvé par la durée et l'intensité
de la crise
ce ségur de la santé et la traduction de
la volonté de réparer l'hôpital français
d'aujourd'hui et de poser les fondations
de l'hôpital de demain un hôpital plus
humain plus solidaire plus efficace plus
complémentaires du secteur privé avec
plus de moyens mieux allouer mais aussi
et surtout plus attentif à la
préservation de sa vraie richesse
un bien commun un patrimoine national je
veux dire c'est personnel monsieur le
ministre
après ma santé 2022 après la reprise
d'un tiers de la dette de deux hôpitaux
maintenant ce ségur et sans oublier la
création d'une cinquième branche de la
sécurité sociale consacrée à l'autonomie
qu'elles seront demain vos nouveaux axes
prioritaires en matière de politique
hospitalière et plus généralement
de santé publique je vous remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé je remercie
monsieur le député philippe chalumeau
pour pour votre question qui porte sur
les accords du ségur de la santé vous
avez raison d'abord d'en souligner
l'ampleur l'ampleur 7,6 milliards de
revalorisation pour plus d'un million et
demi de salariés des hôpitaux publics
associatifs privés ehpad publics
associative privé au plus de 80% des
femmes qui prennent soin de nous quand
on a besoin qu'on prenne soin de nous
avec des métiers qui sont sous valorisés
sous payés et ce depuis des décennies
7,6 milliards d'euros monsieur le député
c'est 40 x 40 x les dernière
revalorisation salariale hospitalière
quarante fois voilà pour les chiffres
monsieur le député vous souligne
également qu'un accord a été trouvé avec
les organisations médicales qui permet
de favoriser l'attractivité des
carrières dans la durée de favoriser
aussi les débuts de carrière des
médecins hospitaliers qu'on a tant de
mal à pouvoir trouver et garder dans un
exercice hospitalier et nous avons fait
le choix et les syndicats ont fait le
choix de prioriser c'est vrai les
médecins dont l'exercice est
exclusivement public sans activité
privée entre autres mesures qui ont été
mises en place et ce matin j'ai eu
l'honneur et le plaisir de signer des
accords avec les externes en médecine
avec les internes de médecine générale
et les internes de médecine spécialisée
ce qui veut dire monsieur le député que
la boucle est bouclée en matière
d'accord et que le ségur est à la
hauteur de l'ambition qui avait été fixé
par le président de la république et
soutenu activement par le premier
ministre qui avait rajouté on le
rappelle un milliard d'euros et annoncé
la création de quinze mille emplois
supplémentaires à l'hôpital
ça fait combien d'années qu'on n'avait
pas dit qu'il fallait créer des postes à
l'hôpital quand on était dans l'exécutif
ça fait combien d'années qu'on n'avait
pas dit qu'il fallait ouvrir des lits
dans l'hôpital quand on était dans
l'exécutif et bien nous l'avons dit et
nous le
ferron merci monsieur le ministre la
parole est à monsieur dominique potier
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse aux
nouveaux ministres de l'agriculture
nous sommes loin du discours de rungis
du président la république nous sommes
loin des espérances nées des états
généraux de l'alimentation et je le dis
sincèrement avec le groupe socialiste
nous partageons la déception traduite
par l'observatoire des prix il ya
quelques jours non pour les éleveurs
pour le lait pour la viande égal il n'a
pas été au rendez vous c'est un échec et
nous devons l'assumer ensemble d'autant
plus que d'autant d'autant plus que
sapin de que nous avions nous même
initié sur le volet agricole n'avait pas
tenu tous les espoirs suscités
donc il faut regarder les choses en face
et nous reste deux ans pour agir
nous vous proposons michel ministre
d'investir trois champs qui peuvent
sauver ce mandat être utile au monde
agricole
le premier touche à une loi foncière 50
% des agriculteurs prendre leur retraite
dans les dix ans qui viennent
l'accaparement des terres est un
appauvrissement économique sociale
écologique
nous avons besoin face aux dérives
ultralibérales de retrouver une
régulation du foncier pour assurer une
relève générationnelle est assurée
l'esprit d'entreprise dans nos campagnes
deuxième champ il est celui de la
politique agricole commune
je le regrette mais il semble que la
france ne soit pas assez investi dans le
green deal est le lien et le levier
qu'elle peut constituer dans la
politique agricole et alimentaire
commune avec notamment quatre leviers
monsieur le ministre que nous tenons
nous invitons dialogue avec nous sur ces
sujets le premier celui de mobiliser le
premier pilier sur les organismes de
producteurs pour la fabrique des volumes
et des prix à la base tels que égal il
n'a pas pu le faire
le deuxième est celui de mobiliser
deuxième pilier sur la haute valeur
environnementale pour relancer le récit
de l'agro écologie qui réconcilie
société agriculture le troisième vous le
savez très bien c'est celui d'une
autonomie protéique par des aides
découplées tous ces leviers ils sont à
votre portée et le dernier le plus
important c'est d'apporter ici
maintenant la garantie que la france
dans le cadre du traité mix qui pourrait
connaître une accélération dans la
présidence allemande mettra son veto
mercosur pour le club de normandie
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député dominique
potier il s'avère que l'un des premiers
rapports que j'ai lus en prenant mes
fonctions et un rapport que vous aviez
fait avec un laurent speitel sur en
décembre 2018 sur la question du foncier
et dans ce rapport vous dites il y a
deux mots clés pour l'agriculture
française c'est protéger et partager
je connais vos valeurs j'en partage
beaucoup et je peux vous dire que ces
deux axes protéger et partager ce sont
les sacs ce que nous devons suivre pour
la politique agricole et ça me permet de
ce fait de répondre à un certain nombre
de vos questions sur le foncier
il faut protéger nos agriculteurs de
l'artificialisation des sols
quand je vois que le premier ministre
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale à après un moratoire sur tous
les nouveaux centres commerciaux pour
éviter notamment que un certain nombre
de terres agricoles ne puisse être mangé
par ses centres commerciaux
ça va dans ce sens dans la question du
foncier sur les statuts le fermage et la
proposition de loi que vous portez moi
je suis tout à fait prêt à avancer
est-ce que c'est sur un vecteur
législatif ou autre peu m'importe le
danger aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y ait
plus de transmissions du foncier et donc
nous devons avancer dessus et puis le
deuxième volet protéger c'est aussi
protéger l'agriculture l'environnement
et à ce titre le président de la
république l'a redit le 29 juin
oui la france s'opposera au mercosur il
a dit devant les 150 citoyens de la
convention pour le climat enfin le
deuxième grand axe c'est partager et
partager ça veut dire que l'alimentation
française
elle doit pouvoir être accessible à tous
les français c'est la question de la
souveraineté alimentaire qui est en jeu
que vous appelez au site de votre voeu
ça veut dire qu'il faut dans le plan de
relance et nous en avons beaucoup
discuté que par exemple le plan
protéines soit un des vecteurs du plan
de relance
c'est la souveraineté alimentaire et je
j'ai commencé par un rapport
parlementaire
je terminerai par un autre rapport
alimentaire celui que vous avez fait
monsieur potier avec différents groupes
sébastien jumel
julien dive monsieur ramos il m'en
manque un pardon et stéphane travert mon
ami stéphane travert ce qui j'étais et
ben oui il y à cette souveraineté
alimentaire mais l'essentiel et je salue
se défend derrière chez le ministre
vous faites bien inciter les grands
auteurs qui produisent des rapports
parlementaires qui devrait plus souvent
inspiré l'action du gouvernement
la parole
vous allez le faire rougir
la parole est à monsieur pierre henri
dumont monsieur le premier ministre
dimanche votre ministre de l'intérieur
était à calais pour rencontrer les
forces de l'ordre qui lutte contre
l'immigration irrégulière une visite de
plus d'un ministre de l'intérieur de
plus pour qu'au final rien ne change
pour les habitants les entreprises du
calaisis vivent dans l'insécurité
permanente
les pacers ont d'ailleurs envoyé un
message très clair puisque ce même jour
180 migrants traversé illégalement la
manche un record quand il s'agit de la
sécurité des français
seuls les actes importe en cela vous
êtes comptable monsieur le premier
ministre du bilan catastrophique du
président macron ces trois dernières
années l'insécurité a explosé dans notre
pays et partout l'autorité de l'état
recul des gendarmes se font assassiner
des bandes rivales s'échangent des
rafales d'armes automatiques
un chauffeur de bus se fait lyncher pour
un ticket trois masques des pompiers en
intervention sont visés par des tirs
d'armes à feu plus aucune manifestation
ne se déroule sans violence
ces trois dernières années le
communautarisme a gangréné des pans
entiers de notre pays le voile dans
l'espace public n'est pas à la sphère du
président les mosquées salafistes reste
ouverte
les 3000 étrangères a dit radicaliser ne
sont pas expulsés les femmes sont
exclues de certains lieux publics
ces trois dernières années l'immigration
est devenue hors de contrôle
le nombre de titres de séjour a augmenté
de 20 % moins de 10% des obligations de
quitter le territoire sont exécutés le
débat sur la politique migratoire n'a
suscité qu'un compréhension déception et
désillusion
monsieur le premier ministre avec votre
nomination on promettait un changement
de cap
ce cap fut tracé le 14 juillet quand le
président de la république en 80 minutes
d'interview à acter son échec sur la
sécurité en restant muet sur le sujet
avec emmanuel macron la france et
transformé en un pays où la violence est
devenue le principal moyen d'expression
l'impunité pour les délinquants la norme
et l'autorité de l'état une chimère avez
vous monsieur le premier ministre
conscience de l'état de déliquescence
dans lequel se trouve notre pays
avez vous conscience de l'urgence de
réarmer l'état allez-vous faire du
rétablissement de l'autorité de l'état
la priorité absolue des deux dernières
années de votre quinquennat
merci monsieur le député la parole de
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député du monde je vous
parlais très vite je n'ai pas tout
compris mais j'ai compris j'ai compris
que le taux de votre question était très
différent de l'accueil républicain vous
me remercier d'être venu trois jours
après la nomination dans la jolie ville
de calais 1 je regrette que votre
présentation de votre territoire ne sont
pas plus positif pour tous les habitants
qui habitent
monsieur le député monsieur le député
nous connaissons tous les deux très bien
notre région et permettez-moi d'associer
brigitte bourguignon qui connaît je
crois très bien également le pas de
calais et vous avez raison sur un
certain point il y a à calais un
problème migratoire qui remontent depuis
longtemps qui n'est pas le fait des
calaisiens bien évidemment et qui n'est
pas si vous me permettez non plus le
fait de la politique de la république
française trois gouvernements successifs
mais bien le fait qu'effectivement des
gens nos souvent souvent la peur la
détresse la pauvreté sur les trafics
aussi des passeurs vous le savez bien
profite de ce passage facile avec
l'angleterre pour pouvoir se poser de
manière tout à fait illégale sur le
territoire calaisien dès ma prise de
fonction et vous le savez très bien
monsieur le député lendemain j'ai
demandé à monsieur le préfet du pas de
calais d'ordonner une expulsion c'est
800 migrants qui était revenu sur le
territoire du calaisis 500 et vous le
savez très bien ont pu être évacués je
me suis rendu avec madame schiappa sur
place et j'ai discuté non seulement avec
vous avec les policiers qui font un
travail formidable que je voudrais ici
évoquée mais aussi que la maire de
calais et j'ai fait ce qu a misé
intérieure n'a pas fait depuis longtemps
j'ai demandé à mon homologue britannique
qui est venu 48 heures après ma demande
à calais visiter avec moi les forces de
l'ordre et travailler ensemble pour que
non seulement on puisse renforcer les
moyens de sécurité à calais mais surtout
lutter contre l'immigration illégale
vous verrez dans quelques jours que cela
n'est pas un vain mot merci monsieur le
ministre la parole à madame pascale
boyer
monsieur le ministre c'est au nom de mon
collègue aurélia morenas député du
vaucluse et moi même que j'interviens
aujourd'hui au cours de la crise
sanitaire les français ont re découvert
que l'agriculture française les
nourrissait nos agriculteurs ont fait
tenir le système alors remercier
sincèrement une nouvelle fois pourtant
la crise a montré des points de
fragilité
il est désormais urgent d'identifier les
points de faiblesse et les points qui
auraient pu être bloquant si la crise
s'était prolongée j'en veux pour exemple
la preuve même à la problématique du
déficit de la main d'oeuvre saisonnière
conséquence de la fermeture des
frontières et une nouvelle fermeture des
frontières mettrait en péril le
ramassage des prochaines récoltes
c'est pourquoi la question d'un régime
proprement français a été ravivée
d'autres sujets sont également étudiés
l'amélioration des circuits logistiques
de distribution et de transformation des
matières premières l'augmentation des
prix des produits alimentaires les
marges de la grande distribution les
distorsions de concurrence
intra-européenne sociales et
environnementales et les exportations de
notre savoir faire agricoles vers des
marchés à forte expansion démographique
l'attractivité des territoires ruraux
passe évidemment par les conditions de
vie qu'il est possible d'y trouver mais
cela n'est pas suffisant
cette attractivité reste conditionné au
soutien que nous pourrons apporter au
maintien ou à l'implantation de nos
entreprises rurales dans les secteurs
agricole et agroalimentaire
alors que la volonté du premier ministre
et d'engager prochainement une
conférence avec les territoires
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre
quels sont vos orientations en matière
de souveraineté agricoles et
alimentaires et quels seront vos actions
pour que les acteurs des territoires
soient pleinement associées au plan de
relance je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur julien de normandie ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
madame la députée pascale boyer vous
avez raison vous avez raison de mettre
en avant celles et ceux qui pendant la
crise sanitaire ont permis aux français
de tenir le 14 juillet dernier
la france a rendu un hommage appuyé à
toutes celles et ceux qui étaient en
première ligne au front les soignants
l'après midi même
je me suis rendu dans une exploitation
agricole parce que je voulais par ce
geste témoigne est aussi en cette
journée d'hommage la reconnaissance de
la république vis-à-vis des agriculteurs
des éleveurs des pêcheurs de toutes
celles et ceux qui ont tenu et qui ont
permis à tous les français d'avoir accès
à leur chaîne alimentaire
la deuxième le deuxième point c'est
quelle est la vision que nous devons
avoir de cette politique agricole et
alimentaire
elle est assez simple c'est la
souveraineté agricole et la souveraineté
alimentaire française parce qu'on ne dit
pas suffisamment mais depuis quelques
depuis quelques mois la santé est au
centre de tout notre discussion
mais l'alimentation c'est au centre de
notre santé et quelle est la meilleure
alimentation au monde et d'un c'est
l'alimentation française grâce à
l'agriculture française et donc le sujet
il est simple c'est la souveraineté
agricoles et alimentaires françaises et
pour ça il ya beaucoup de sujets sur
lequel il faut continuer à avancer je
rends hommage à mes prédécesseurs
stéphane travert et didier guillaume il
faut continuer à avancer sur le juste
prix parce que oui aujourd'hui le juste
prix il n'est pas encore là et donc il
faut continuer à avancer il faut avancer
dans l'investissement sur l'agroécologie
parce que les premiers à souhaiter cette
transformation
ce sont les agriculteurs eux-mêmes il
faut continuer à avancer sur la
structuration de la filière alimentaire
parce que aujourd'hui c'est un tissu de
pme et deux pays il faut continuer à les
aider et c'est un sujet du plan de
relance notamment dans les circuits
courts
et puis enfin il faut que cette
politique agricole elles soient sociales
parce que cette alimentation française
elle doit bénéficier à tous les français
et c'est là aussi un des éléments sur
lequel le premier ministre m'a demandé
de travailler
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur alain bruneel monsieur le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
pour les soignants de l'espoir il y en
avait au début de la crise du
coronavirus lorsque le président de la
république avait déclaré je le cite que
la santé n'avait pas de prix et qu'il
souhaitait décliner un grand plan massif
d'investissements pour l'hôpital les
soignants étaient des héros selon les
propres termes du plan la république des
génies selon vos propres mots monsieur
le ministre
entre-temps aînés le ségur de la santé
énième consultation avec les soignants
puis le 14 juillet est arrivée avec son
décorum joliment poser pour les métiers
de première ligne dont les soignants le
défilé le grand palais la place de la
concorde
les médailles et une marseillaise
entonnée à l'unisson le même jour à
paris et ailleurs en france des milliers
de soignants ont manifesté pour exprimer
leur déception face aux accords de ségur
car aujourd'hui force est de constater
que le ségur n'a pas fière allure et rim
avec 2000 mesure c'est aussi de poids et
de ségur car il n'a pas à la hauteur des
attentes exprimées par une majorité de
soignants si les augmentations de
salaires vont certes améliorer
l'ordinaire
les calculs sont vite faits les 183
euros permettent juste de rattraper la
perte de pouvoir d'achat à accumuler
depuis 2010 du fait du blocage des
salaires dans la fonction publique de
mobilisation en mobilisation je
rappellerai que ces augmentations ont
été arrachés de haute lutte par les
soignants dans la rue depuis de nombreux
mois les personnels hospitaliers ne sont
pas des marchands de tapis
il demande 300 euros par mois ce n'est
pas de l'aumône c'est une revalorisation
légitime
il revendique l'arrêt des plans de
retour à l'équilibré financier la
ouvertures de lits pour les patients et
demande à être plus nombreux pour ne pas
être épuisées au travail
monsieur le ministre ses revendications
n'ont toujours pas trouvé de réponse
merci chers collègues la parole câble
chez olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de la santé
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député brunel il ya quelques
contre vérités dans la question que vous
avez posé je voudrais revenir calmement
dessus d'abord je ne sais pas si vous
étiez au 14 juillet sur la place de la
concorde
en tout cas vous ne mettiez je crois que
vous n'y étiez pas ni la veille au soir
lorsque j'avais invité 800 soignants
investi dans le combat contre le coc
vide dans un certain nombre avaient
perdu des membres de leur famille je
peux vous dire que l'émotion était
palpable tout au long de la soirée
tout au long de la cérémonie et que
personne personne sur place ne remettait
en question l'intérêt majeur pour la
nation de rendre hommage à ces soignants
à travers cette belle cérémonie du 14
juillet je peux vous dire que j'en
garderai un souvenir avis vous parler
ensuite des revalorisations et des 300
euros monsieur le député lisez la
totalité des accords lisait d'ailleurs
vous dites que ces accords ne sont
rejetées par une majorité
monsieur le député vous êtes député
communiste les accords salariaux
syndicaux ça vous parle
un accord majoritaire ça vous parle
monsieur le député lorsque vous avez
l'unsa la cfdt force ouvrière qui
signent un accord l'accord devient dès
lors majoritaire respecter le dialogue
social je le sais que vous le faites
respecter le aussi quand il vient de
nous cet accord salarial monsieur le
député vous citez la première des trois
mesures de revalorisation les 183 euros
nets qui vont concerner tout le monde
de l'électricien à la sage femme en
passant par l'infirmière
l'aide-soignante la shm 1,5 million de
soignants l'hôpital il y à une deuxième
ligne dorval de revalorisation c'est ce
qu'on appelle le travail sur les grilles
indiciaires en moyenne 35 euros net de
plus par mois pour tous les soignants et
les métiers médicaux techniques on est
déjà à 220 euros
ajoutez donc la troisième ligne monsieur
le député celle de l'aïd l'engagement
collectif et vous passer quasiment 300
euros et quand vous ajoutez la 4e si
d'aventuré une infirmière swerts
souhaite faire des heures
supplémentaires elles seront majorées à
50% jusqu'à 5 heures supplémentaires par
semaine
et là vous exploser les 300 euros
monsieur le député est à 450 vous êtes
parfois même à 500 euros
c'est la plus forte revalorisation de
salaire personne n'ira que c'est trop
tout le monde ya accès juste au moins
reconnaissez le
steve monsieur le député brunel alors
permettez moi monsieur le ministre de
partager aussi l'émotion qui était vécue
lors du 14 juillet parce que cette
émotion elle était vécu bien avant le 14
juillet elle est applaudie par les
citoyens dans les quartiers
elle était vécue dans les hôpitaux et
aussi par le génie comme vous disais
d'aidés soignants alors quand vous dites
qu à 300 euros mais pourquoi ils sont
pas dans la fille de salaire pourquoi
ils sont pas dans le gris jeu là
pourquoi ils sont décortiqués comme ça
vous ne prenez pas les moyens monsieur
le ministre si monsieur députés la
parole est à vous la même constance ce
gris merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous nous
avez dit hier dans votre déclaration de
politique générale ne pas vouloir
augmenter les impôts bien
il est vrai que la france est déjà
championne d'europe des prélèvements
obligatoires il n'est nul besoin d'en
rajouter en effet mais en même temps en
même temps le chef de l'état dans son
interview télévisée du 14 juillet a
évoqué comme une option possible
l'idée de décaler un peu je reprends ses
propres termes pour les plus fortunés
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
quand il dit les plus fortunés le
présent macron pas des 20% de français
qui payent encore la taxe d'habitation
c'est à dire ceux des français qui ont
des revenus supérieurs à 2500 euros par
mois autant dire les classes moyennes et
donc pour ces classes moyennes la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation qui
était l'un des engagements forts de la
campagne du candidat final maquereau en
2017 est repoussée aux calendes grecques
une telle décision si elle devait être
confirmée serait en contradiction totale
non seulement avec une promesse de
campagne mais également avec les
engagements du gouvernement et avec la
trajectoire de suppression la taxe
d'habitation prévu par la loi de
programmation des finances publiques
elle représenterait une hausse d'impôts
je dis bien une hausse d'impôt et
rendrai cet impôt terriblement injuste
en le concentrant sur ceux des français
qui ont des revenus
moyen autant dire les classes moyennes
toujours et encore considérés comme des
vaches à lait et je rajoute le conseil
constitionnel a lui-même eu l'occasion
de le dire si la taxe d'habitation doit
être supprimée elle doit être supprimé
pour tout le monde au nom du principe
d'égalité devant l'impôt
alors monsieur le premier ministre la
question est très simple
sortez de l'ambiguïté et dites-nous
quand la taxe d'habitation sera supprimé
pour l'ensemble des français
merci débuté la parole à madame agnès
pannier prudence ministre délégué à
l'industrie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
constance le grip je me réjouis
d'entendre ce plaidoyer flamboyant pour
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
je m'en réjouis d'autant plus que je ne
crois pas avoir autant entendu cet
enthousiasme ses trois précédentes
années sur les bancs et je constate
qu'en fin enfin vous reconnaissez ce
geste inédit qui consiste à supprimer 20
milliards d'euros de taxes sur
l'ensemble des ménages français et je
veux tout de suite vous rassurer parce
que comme vous l'avez très bien dit il
n'est pas question de ne pas supprimer
la taxe d'habitation est d'ailleurs le
conseil constitutionnel l'a dit c'est
une question d'égalité des français
devant la peau il est peut-être question
peut-être question peut-être pour
certains des 20% des français de
légèrement repoussé cette baisse
d'impôts mais je veux vous rassurer
aussi les 5 milliards d'impôts sur le
revenu des personnes physiques que nous
avons supprimé cette année et qui
touchent des classes populaires qui
travaillent les classes moyennes qui
travaillent
celle-là c'est 5 milliards de là ils
seront bien diminué cette année et les
30 milliards d'impôts que nous avons
baissé depuis le début du set du
quinquennat ils sont bien aujourd'hui
dans les comptes dans la poche des
français
550 euros en moyenne d'augmentation du
pouvoir d'achat pour les ménages francs
ses 17 millions de ménages français
alors merci madame le député de nous
donner l'occasion de montrer à quel
point notre politique fiscale a été
orientée au service des français qui
travaillent au service des français qui
ont été denses et première ligne pendant
la crise du coc vite 19 au service des
français qui contribuent à construire
notre force économique et le lien social
sur le territoire
merci madame nominés la parole est à
madame caroline fiat
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
été chargé du déconfinement et si
nécessaire dur confinement c'est à ce
titre que je vous interroge dans
l'hypothèse d'une seconde vague comme le
craint monsieur salomon le dgs pensez
vous que nos établissements de santé
leurs personnels sont prêts à y faire
face si celle-ci arrivé en 2020 ta
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités de l'affronter madame la
députée carli fiat
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que au
total dix sept mille patients ont été
admis en réanimation au cours de la
première vague et que nous avons armées
et les médecins les soignants ont armé
les lits de réanimation des hôpitaux et
des cliniques de france de manière à
être en mesure si nécessaire
d'accueillir jusqu'à trente mille
malades
je peux vous dire madame la députée
qu'il nous disposons désormais d'un
stock pour pour faire face à six
semaines de besoin au moins en
consommation de produits anesthésiques
et que nous disposons après avoir
commandé près de 4 milliards de masques
du matériel de protection nécessaires
pour nos hôpitaux nos soignants sont
fatigués madame la députée nos soignants
ont besoin de repos et il n'est pas
question d'aller je dirais par les
comportements individuels ou collectifs
prendre le risque de faire repartir
l'épidémie dans notre pays vont poser
une question pour savoir si nous sommes
prêts je vous réponds que nous faisons
le maximum pour l'être pour faire face
aux éventualités les plus compliqués et
les plus douloureuses toutefois je
profite de votre question pour redire
aux français que nous devons faire
preuve d'une vigilance constante au
cours des jours et des semaines à venir
les français qui le souhaitent pourront
se faire tester sur leurs lieux
vacances ils pourront accéder à des
masques ils pourront accéder à des
consultations médicales
ils pourront accéder à de la
téléconsultation c'est comme ça madame
la députée qu'on évite de devoir se
poser la question de savoir si les
hôpitaux peuvent faire face à une
deuxième vague
merci monsieur l'islam à ce jour les
personnels travaillent toujours en mode
dégradé pénurie de gand à venir sur
blues en sacs poubelles absence de mac
ffp2 dans certains établissements
sous-effectif
ce ne sont pas des annonces pour 2021
qui aideront si la vague arrive en 2020
ce ségur de la santé est une arnaque
rien sur l'attractivité de nos métiers
vous vous demandez bouche bée pourquoi
les personnels ne sont pas satisfaits de
votre ségur sans une augmentation de 300
euros vous pouvez doubler le nombre de
postes vacants
vous ne trouverez personne poulet pour
voir on parle de santé voulez-vous
revivent l'hécatombe de la première
vague dans nos epad le cauchemar dans
nos hôpitaux
à ce jour nous avons moins de lits
qu'avant la crise quand le patron de
renault est venu vous réclamer de
l'argent vous ne lui avez pas répondu on
va faire un ségur des voitures bim 8
milliards quand le patron d'air france
est venu vous réclamer de l'argent vous
ne lui avez pas répondu on va faire un
ségur des avions vim
8 milliards mais dès qu'il s'agit de la
santé des français vous freiner des
quatre fers inadmissible quand vous
donnez 8 milliards air france pour
supprimer 8000 emplois dites vous bien
que nous sur ces bancs 6,8 milliards
d'argent public nous les aurions mis
dans les ehpad et créer 210 mille
emplois monsieur le premier ministre non
nos établissements de santé ne sont pas
prêts vous ne leur donnez pas les moyens
de l'être
qu'attendez vous pour débloquer les
fonds dès aujourd'hui pour que plus
jamais nous ayons à subir le cauchemar
de la première vague et qu'enfin nous
puissions traiter dignement nos patients
et nos résidents
merci madame fiat monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je ne vous répondrai pas sur air france
madame la députée car je suis mise et
solidarité de la santé vous interroger
sur larnack du ségur
madame la députée vous avez été vous
avez été comme je l'étais mais vous
l'avez été plus longtemps que moi aide
soignante
le salaire moyen d'une aide soignante
madame la députée les 2003 157 euros
nets par mois 1357 euros net par mois
les aides soignants de notre pays après
le ségur gagneront au minimum 220 euros
net par mois de plus je pense madame la
députée madame la députée vous qui êtes
si prompte à considérer que 5 euros par
mois c'est un drame je vole des 220
euros par mois ce n'est pas un drame ce
n'est pas un cadeau c'est juste
reconnaissez le là je crois que vous
n'êtes pas raisonnable madame la députée
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur m jid el
guerrab merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
franck riester permettez moi de
commencer ma question par une petite
devinette quel est le point commun entre
edouard philippe
emmanuelle béart gad elmaleh ou encore
philippe seguin paix à son âme
que cela soit à bonn montréal casablanca
ou tunis ils ont été à un moment de leur
vie des français de l'étranger célèbres
ou anonymes
nos 3 5 millions de compatriotes qui
vivent à l'étranger
on la france chevillée au coeur mais ils
ont hélas parfois le sentiment d'être
oubliés dans les récentes prises de
paroles majeur qui trace le chemin des
deux années proche des 2 années
prochaines
ils n'ont pas été évoquées
malheureusement hors de retour de ma
circonscription où j'étais hier en
tunisie
j'ai constaté leur inquiétude et
notamment celle liée à l'impossibilité
de pouvoir revenir en france
ainsi monsieur le ministre si je n'ai
jamais cessé de louer le travail
exceptionnel réalisé par les agents de
votre ministère qui a permis le retour
de 250000 français de passage il est
grand temps de concentrer nos efforts
sur la situation de nos compatriotes à
l'étranger qui craignent également pour
leur emploi il y a également de grandes
craintes liées au maintien de notre
réseau d'écoles français
à l'étranger que beaucoup de pays nous
envient ainsi que sur l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire face à la menace
d'une deuxième vague nos postes
consulaires nos élus des français de
l'étranger
nous associations tout notre tissu
d'entrepreneurs des français du monde
attendent des mots et des gestes forts à
leur égard paul valéry disait comment
peut-on être si loin de ce que l'on a de
plus près nos compatriotes à l'étranger
n'en attendent pas moins de la part de
leur mère patrie la france je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
monsieur franck riester ministre délégué
chargé du commerce extérieur et de
l'attractivité merci beaucoup monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député gherram merci de
votre question vous qui êtes un ardent
défenseur non seulement des français
établis hors de france mais aussi des
français de passage à l'étranger
notamment et particulièrement depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
à la demande du président de la
république le gouvernement est mobilisé
aussi depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire pour d'abord assurer le
rapatriement de nos compatriotes de
passage à l'étranger sous la houlette de
jean yves le drian est en lien direct
avec le ministre des transports la
compagnie air france d'autres compagnies
aériennes françaises et étrangères
le gouvernement a veillé chaque jour à
trouver des solutions aux 250 mille de
nos compatriotes qui étaient à
l'étranger au moment du début du
confinement
aujourd'hui à part quelques exceptions
ils ont tous trouvé des solutions et
sont revenus en france
mais le gouvernement ne s'arrête pas
simplement à ces français de passage à
l'étranger il se concentre aussi sur
ceux qui sont établis hors de france
avec un plan de soutien de plus de 200
millions d'euros qui a été mobilisé pour
à la fois apporter des aides médicales à
nos compatriotes qui en auraient besoin
à hauteur de 20 millions d'euros
des aides qui concerne l'aide sociale
pour ceux qui sont les plus en
difficultés financières et près de 135
millions d'euros pour accompagner les
familles qui ont des enfants scolarisés
dans le réseau de l'enseignement
français à l'étranger
vous voyez monsieur le député que le
prétend la république tout le
gouvernement est mobilisée au service de
nos compatriotes établis hors de france
je vous reviens
6 merci monsieur le ministre la parole
est à monsieur frédéric reiss
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
dans une période de grave crise
sanitaire économique et social
l'annnonce de la vente du site alstom de
reichshoffen a été un véritable coup de
massue pour les salariés et leurs
familles certes le rachat de bombardier
transport par alstom était depuis
quelques mois sur les rails d'une
demande toujours croissante de mobilité
durable
à ceux qui voulaient connaître la
stratégie industrielle de ce nouveau
géant ferroviaire et avoir des garanties
sur les emplois monsieur poupart-lafarge
répondait qu'il était normal que ce type
d'opération créer une phase
d'incertitude mais qu'elle ne menacera
pas l'emploi car je le cite le nouveau
groupe aura besoin de tous les talents
or après le mariage avorté avec siemens
alstom anticipe les exigences de la
commission européenne qui pourrait lui
reprocher fin juillet une position
dominante sur le marché des trains
régionaux
n'avons nous pas là l'illustration d'une
union européenne incapable de laisser
émerger des champions industriels de
taille mondiale en europe
n'est-il pas urgent d'adapter le droit
européen à la concurrence comme le
préconise le rapport le grip anatot de
novembre 2019
parmi les sacrifices consentis la vente
du site de production de reichshoffen
pose de nombreuses questions
quel accord quel effectif que
deviendront les 730 salariés
la centaine d'intérimaires les 130 sous
traitants le site alsacien va-t-il
passer aux mains d'un groupe européen où
le loup chinois va-t-il entrer dans la
bergerie européenne l'union européenne
n'était elle pas en train de se tirer
une balle dans le pied
monsieur le premier ministre le site de
reichshoffen qui a fêté ses 250 ans de
savoir faire industriel a un potentiel
d'innovation exceptionnelle pour les
trains du futur
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur la
pérennité du site et de ses activités
merci chers collègues la parole à madame
agnès pannier rynnas ministre délégué à
l'industrie
[Applaudissements]
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur lé député reiss
vous avez raison de souligner que le
rachat du de bombardier par alstom va
créer un groupe qui aura la deuxième
position mondiale dans le secteur des
transports ferroviaires
c'est en soi une bonne nouvelle pour
l'industrie française une bonne nouvelle
à un moment où le alstom représentent 8
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
et décroché en termes de chiffre
d'affaires par rapport au géant chinois
crc qui en représente à peu près 26
milliards d'euros
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
l'industrie française c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour l'industrie européenne
il ne m'appartient pas de rentrer dans
le détail des discussions entre la
commission européenne et alstom vous
connaissez nos positions sur la
politique de la concurrence vous
connaissez nos propositions qui ont été
formulées très clairement au moment du
rapprochement entre siemens et alstom
qui a avorté
et vous savez qu il nous semble
important de faire évoluer cette ce
droit de la concurrence pour l'adapter à
la réalité de la compétition mondiale et
nous allons continuer à y travailler
mais je veux revenir à un instant sur la
situation du site de reichshoffen
d'abord pour dire comme vous que c'est
un site qui est particulièrement
compétitif avec des technologies qui
sont particulièrement bien maîtrisée et
un carnet de commandes particulièrement
bien fourni puisqu'il courra jusqu'en
cela veut dire que ce site à toutes les
potentialités pour intéresser des grands
acteurs de qualité et que nous serons
aux côtés des reprises des salariés et
de leurs représentants pour s'assurer de
trouver le meilleur acheteur si nous
devons aller sur cela ce n'est pas
encore totalement tranché mais en tout
état de cause si c'était la solution qui
était retenu notre engagement notre
responsabilité est d'avoir un projet
industriel durable clair pour les
salariés et qui permettent à
reichshoffen peut continuer à être au
sommet de son art dans le domaine
ferroviaire
merci madame la ministre la parole était
madame aude luquet merci merci monsieur
le président mes chers collègues
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique vous êtes rendu samedi
dernier en seine et marne au coeur de la
forêt de fontainebleau qui prétend un
classement au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco et qui attire chaque année plus
de 11 millions de personnes fois
d'exception de par la richesse de sa
biodiversité et sa géologie particulière
son territoire est menacé par le
réchauffement climatique
les épisodes caniculaires de ces
dernières années ont asséché les sols et
brûler les arbres
ces phénomènes désastreux sont de plus
en plus nombreux en france et touche de
nombreuses forêts la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique doit donc être
le moteur de votre action madame la
ministre et répondre à une politique
volontariste et transversales
volontariste d'abord car dans ma
circonscription par exemple nous menons
avec d'autres élus de mon territoire un
combat depuis plus de dix ans pour faire
interdire la traversée quotidienne de
milliers de poids lourds dans la forêt
de fontainebleau et la ville de melun
les nuisances sonores sont
insupportables pour les riverains et les
émissions de polluants atmosphériques
sont dangereuses pour la faune et la
flore pourtant les axes de contournement
existent
madame la ministre les élus de nos
territoires demande votre appui pour
mener de cette politique volontariste de
notre biodiversité a tant besoin
au delà du volontarisme devant en france
et la transversalité des actions vous
avez juste titre exprimé le souhait que
tous les mystères soit dotée d'une
feuille de route verte sur les vous
favorable au renforcement des missions
des hauts fonctionnaires au
développement durable déjà présents au
sein de chaque ministère
enfin je regrette la disparition du tarn
solidarité dans l'intitulé de votre
ministère alors qu'il nous faut plus que
jamais des chèques concitoyens être un
acteur de la transition écologique
quelles que soient ses moyens pour en
être pour en tirer individuellement et
collectivement des bénéfices
comment comptez vous faire vivre cette
notion de solidarité au sein de votre
ministère je vous en remercie merci v'là
le député la parole de madame barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique
merci merci monsieur le président
madame la députée au de l'udc et merci
pour votre question je suis
effectivement venu dans cette magnifique
forêt de fontainebleau
samedi dernier pour illustrer le travail
fantastique qui est fait par l'office
français de la biodiversité et salué les
agents de l'eau nf parce que
effectivement vous avez raison la
question de la gestion de la forêt pour
faire face aux enjeux du changement
climatique est essentiel sinon nous
risquons de la perdre et c'est un enjeu
absolument essentiel je salue d'ailleurs
anne laure quatre lots que je vois
derrière vous qui a fait un excellent
rapport sur le sujet et qui va beaucoup
nous inspirer sur le sujet des poids
lourds qui traversent la forêt de
fontainebleau
vous le savez les études des études de
déplacement sont en cours dans le cadre
du contrat d'intérêt national de melun
et on va regarder on va être attentif
aux conclusions et aux propositions de
ses études de circulation afin de
trouver le meilleur compromis avec les
acteurs locaux je ne peux pas vous en
dire plus à ce stade sur le fait que
chaque ministère doivent être pleinement
impliqué dans la transition écologique
car oui évidemment je le porte depuis
longtemps et je pense que c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui doit être fait de
manière transversale et c'est pourquoi
le premier ministre va remettre
prochainement à chaque ministre une
feuille de route climat qui reprendra
les budgets carbone de la stratégie
nationale bas carbone et donc chacun
aura sa feuille de route pour avancer
elle devra décliner un ensemble
d'actions que chaque ministère devra
mettre en oeuvre et dont il devra rendre
compte de manière périodique le réseau
des hauts fonctionnaires au
développement durable sera bien
évidemment impliquée dans la mise en
oeuvre et le suivi de ces feuilles de
route et enfin madame la députée sûr
écologique et solidaire ce que j'ai
envie de vous répondre
c'est que écologique et solidaire c'est
un pléonasme et quand on l'oubli on a
des ennuis
je crois que certains mes prédécesseurs
et des gouvernements précédents l'ont vu
quand on met en place des politiques
écologiques mais qu'on ne met pas en
place l'accompagnement social ça ne
fonctionne pas et donc que nous en
tirons les leçons et je peux vous dire
que je serai très attentive à ce que
toutes les politiques écologiques soient
assorties de mesures par exemple la
prime à la conversion pour la voiture
par exemple la prime ne rénove pour la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
merci madame louise monot débuté la
milice vous remercie de votre réponse
sur ma circonscription sûre
particulièrement mon territoire je
voulais vous répondre effectivement il
ya une étude sur les poids lourds ya
4000 véhicules jour donc un moment donné
il faut être là falloir être cohérent
entre la défense de l'environnement et
la traversée des pauvres la forêt de
fontainebleau et sur l'aspect de la
solidarité
je crois qu'il est nécessaire
effectivement d'accompagner les français
pour acheter local merci merci chers
collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à monsieur pierre vatin
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
looks de l'économie et en son absence à
monsieur le ministre chargé des petites
et moyennes entreprises
en premier lieu je souligne mon
étonnement à minima
constatant que hier dans son discours de
politique générale monsieur le premier
ministre n'a pas eu un mot pour les tpe
pme
nos artisans nos commerçants dont un
très grand nombre souffre de la crise
que nous traversons
en second lieu je pense à toutes les
entreprises pour lesquelles les
exonérations de charges sont
insuffisantes au regard de leurs
difficultés et pour lesquels nous les
députés les républicains nous avons
demandé une exonération de charges plus
importantes quand les difficultés sont
plus importante proportionnellement au
chiffre d'affaires afin de leur éviter
la faillite
le dépôt de bilan le chômage pour leurs
salariés comme pour eux mêmes qu'en est
il enfin en troisième lieu
je pense aux tpe pme du bâtiment par
exemple qui ont pu traverser le
confinement parce qu'elles ont poursuivi
leur activité avec courage et
détermination
malgré celui ci mais qui vont très vite
se trouver en difficulté
vous le savez comme moi la reprise
d'activité n'est pas au rendez-vous
aussi fort qu'espéré
de nombreux chefs d'entreprise de
petites entreprises sont inquiets dans
la tente de nouvelles commandes de leurs
donneurs d'ordre ils sont aussi inquiets
quand ils apprennent que leur assureur
crédit les des références du jour au
lendemain sans préavis
au motif fallacieux que leur santé
financière ne serait plus au rendez-vous
alors qu'elle est identique à ce qu'elle
était auparavant
mais sans assurance crédit comment payer
à 45 jours ses fournisseurs quand les
donneurs d'ordres paye hélas à 60 jours
comment avoir un fournisseur qui vous
souhaite de nouveau de la marchandise
alors que votre assureur crédit vous
adhérez français sans motif économique
sérieux si les assureurs crédit ne
jouent pas le jeu dans la crise que nous
traversons
comment dès septembre allez vous éviter
une crise majeure dans les tpe pme des
faillites d'entreprises qui sont
pourtant siens
il est nécessaire à notre économie
comment allez vous évitez du chômage une
récession économique
je vous remercie merci je ferai de la
parole et à monsieur alain griset
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les députés monsieur le député pierre
vatin d'abord je suis heureux que ce
soit un député de la région qui me
posent cette question
d'une façon générale c'est vrai que vous
avez dit les artisans les commerçants
les professionnels libéraux les petites
entreprises sont très présentes sur le
territoire
est ce que j'ai entendu du premier min
sur sa volonté de travailler que les
territoires me rassure par rapport à
cette volonté gouvernementale
vous avez également interrogé sur
l'assurance crédit qui constitue un
levier essentiel de soutien au crédit
interentreprises qui est de loin la
première source de financement de court
terme représentant 700 milliards d'euros
de financement total l'assurance-crédit
couvre environ 200 milliards d'euros de
crédit inter entreprise domestique et
environ 100 milliards d'euros de crédits
et sport le gouvernement a suivi dès le
démarrage de la crise l'évolution des
encours d'assurance crédit
c'est vrai nous avons été alertés par
des entreprises et par des fédérations
professionnelles qui craignait au
constaté un recul de ses couvertures
d'assurance le gouvernement a mis en
place une réponse forte en concertation
avec les autos prix des assureurs pour
assurer le maintien de ses couvertures
d'assurance d'un côté le gouvernement a
proposé un mécanisme de partage de
risques aux assureurs permettant
d'absorber la montée du risque de
défaillance des entreprises qui revêt
une acuité plus particulière dans les
circonstances actuelles nous avons
proposé dès le projet de loi de finances
rectificative numéro 2 la réactivation
des mécanismes capca plus et capte
français sport qui offre des contrats
d'assurance crédit partiellement
rassurés par la caisse centrale de
réassurance dans le projet de loi
rectificative numéro 3 qui est en cours
d'examen au parlement
nous proposons en complément le
dispositif cap prolait qui octroie une
réassurance global des lignes
d'assurance crédit existantes
en contrepartie ces mécanismes de
partage de risques le gouvernement a
fixé des objectifs très clairs aux
assureurs-crédit d'une part le respect
de la convention de 2013 par laquelle
les assureurs se sont engagés à ne pas
procéder à des réductions aux coupures
brutales de lignes de garanties et à
maintenir une information fluide avec
l'état
d'autre part dans le cadre du dispositif
cap rôle et les assurent au crédit se
sont engagées à maintenir les lignes
d'assurance existantes jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour la très grande majorité des
entreprises
nous continuerons mesdames messieurs les
députés à suivre très attentivement le
respect de ses engagements de la part
des assureurs crédit
merci monsieur le ministre je tenais à
ce que monsieur matin est une réponse
totalement complète la parole est à
monsieur jean michel clément
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame nice de la transition
écologique
madame la ministre le 8 juillet dans son
rapport annuel
le haut conseil pour le climat dressé un
constat sévère mais juste de votre
politique en matière de lutte contre le
changement climatique
en résumé la mobilisation des pouvoirs
publics se traduit par très peu
d'avancées concrètes
dans un autre rapport récent le wwf
démontrait pourtant que la transition
écologique et pourvoyeuse d'emplois
territorialisée et pérenne et
nécessitent 14 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires par an d'investissements
entre 2020 et 2025 roi depuis quelques
jours les chiffres et annonces se
multiplient fin juin le président de la
république évoqué 15 milliards d'euros
sur deux ans hier le premier ministre
nous a dit croire en une croissance
écologique plutôt qu'en la décroissance
verte
il a esquissé un plan de relance de 100
milliards dont 20 pour la transition
écologique
la ministre comment et selon quel
calendrier comptez vous répartir ces 20
milliards entre transition énergétique
mobilité durable économie circulaire ou
encore rénovation des bâtiments
c'est sur des chantiers que je veux
insister car il porte une dimension
sociale évidente et je leur ai dit le
cadre actuel ne permettra pas
d'atteindre des objectifs de rénovation
si souvent répéter mes questions sont
simples dans votre plan de relance
combien pour les rénovations du parc
social
combien pour réduire le reste à charge
pour les ménages modestes
comment simplifier les dispositifs
d'accompagnement d'accompagnement il a
été beaucoup question des territoires
hier etes-vous prêts régionaliser les
services énergétiques en confiant région
l'ensemble des financements
enfin pour mobiliser l'épargné des
français le gouvernement est il prêt à
élargir le bénéfice de la prime d'état
des pel vers des opérations de
rénovation énergétique
et je terminerai par une autre marque
même la ministre vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que dans les mandats précédents
les mesures n'avaient pas été suivies
d'effet et vous comprendrez que je serai
attentif à ce que celle que vous allez
prendre le soir merci merci chers
collègues la parole et à madame barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député jean michel clément
vous imaginez bien que moi aussi je vais
être très attentive au suivi des
réformes et d'ailleurs nous avons je
crois chacun dans notre ministère un
membre du cabinet qui est chargé du
suivi de ces réformes je crois que c'est
une très très bonne chose parce
qu'effectivement rien de pire que les
grandes annonces qui ne sont pas suivies
d'effet le haut conseil pour le climat
vous l'avez dit nous a rappelé
l'importance d'accélérer la transition
et pour accélérer la transition il faut
qu'on se base effectivement sur des
mesures qui touchent à des secteurs qui
sont fortement émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre alors d'abord on peut quand
même se réjouir même si c'est peu que
les émissions de la france baisse c'est
déjà une première bonne nouvelle on est
à -0 9% en 2019
mais évidemment c'est insuffisant il y a
déjà quelques mesures qui ont été prises
et y commencent à faire leur effet on le
voit par exemple la prime à la
conversion pour les véhicules qui marche
tellement bien que il va falloir qu'on
la revoit et qu'éventuellement on l'a
centre un peu plus sur des véhicules
encore plus intéressant écologiquement
pour parce qu'elle a un succès énorme
on voit aussi que sur le vélo les choses
avancent beaucoup le confinement a eu un
effet et on voit que les esprits
changent sur le plan de relance en
lui-même 100 milliards d'euros vous
l'avez dit dont une très bonne partie et
ça a été annoncé par le premier ministre
ce matin dont un tiers sera consacrée à
la transition écologique ça nous donne
des moyens pour impulser des dynamiques
très forte dans des domaines importants
sur les domaines les plus importants les
transports évidemment on est sur 30% de
nos émissions
c'est pourquoi on va mettre les moyens
sur des transports le plan vélo un plan
vélo très ambitieux sur le fret
ferroviaire sur les petites lignes ce
sera les grandes priorités
ce sera pas les seuls mais ce sera une
priorité sur le bâtiment je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail parce qu'on est
en train de l'arbitré parce qu'on va
aussi rencontrer les partenaires sociaux
demain pour discuter de ces questions là
mais bien évidemment nous ce qu'on veut
c'est être sur des dispositifs qui soit
efficace sur le fait
rim rénove puissent être mieux employé
et pour que à la fin les personnes les
plus en difficultés puissent en
bénéficier le plus mais ça c'est à
suivre monsieur le député merci madame
le ministre paul d'un monsieur jérôme
lambert
merci monsieur le premier ministre le
président de la république a reconnu
qu'il avait échoué à réconcilier les
français
l'échec du président macron repose sur
une explication les français rejettent
cette politique libérale mise en place
depuis trois ans malheureusement nous
avons compris monsieur le premier
ministre que rien ne serait changée par
votre gouvernement pour corriger la
politique de la france pourtant que des
chèques en particulier sur l'égalité et
les français ils sont très sensibles les
citoyens aujourd'hui sont moins égaux
devant l'impôt qui doit être la juste
contribution de chacun au fonctionnement
des services publics et aux mécanismes
de la solidarité avec votre politique
depuis trois ans les plus fortunés sont
dispensés d'une partie de l'impôt selon
revenu en s'acquittant de la flat tax
plus avantageuse pour eux
en prime évidemment cadeau de l' isf
aussi cela est contraire à l'égalité
voulue par les français et pour laquelle
ils ont été capables de faire la
révolution
échec aussi sur la fraternité
l'abstention massive aux élections
européennes puis municipal montre à quel
point les français se détournent les uns
des autres et du socle commun
démocratique
monsieur le premier ministre la crise
est devant nous et des centaines de
milliards d'euros que vous sortez de
jour en jour de votre manche et que nous
devrons rembourser me font l'effet d'une
lance à incendie
déversées dans le tonneau des danaïdes
vous dépenser sans compter sans rien
remettre de fondamental en cause
vous refusez de faire contribuer les
plus fortunés alors même que certains
parmi eux le demande vous refuser
d'envisager la contribution de 4 % sur
le versement des dividendes des
actionnaires demandé par la convention
citoyenne pour financer la politique en
faveur du climat
ce sont des erreurs majeures ce n'est
pas la majorité que vous avez obtenu
hier dans cet hémicycle qui doit vous
conforter dans ses erreurs pour
réconcilier les français
écouter vraiment les français
ils vous disent tout autre chose pour
l'égalité la fraternité
ils veulent de la justice en tout et une
autre vision de l'avenir famille
monsieur le député la parole tom jeu
gabriel a tall secrétaire d'état porte
parole du gouvernement
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
jérôme lambert
nous avons fait un choix avec le
président de la république en 2017 qui
est de baisser les impôts et de les
baisser pour tout le monde pour tous les
français et ce choix nous en dévierons
pas et c'est ce choix qui a permis
d'arriver au bilan que vous connaissez
avant la crise du coronavirus où nous
étions re devenu le pays le plus
attractif pour les investissements en
europe où nous avions recommencé à créer
de l'emploi industriel dans notre pays
où l'investissement repartaient à la
hausse ou la consommation repartait à la
hausse
il ne vous aura pas échappé que la donne
a changé et qu'elle nécessite de
reconstruire notre pays et nous l'avons
dit et nous l'assumons
nous ne construirons pas notre pays à
l'identique nous le reconstruire on vers
un modèle plus durable vers un modèle
plus juste avec un vrai débat engagé par
le premier ministre et les partenaires
sociaux sur la va sur la répartition de
la valeur dans l'entreprise avec une
vraie politique sociale telle que nous
l'avons engagé depuis plusieurs mois je
vous ai entendu parler d'ultra
libéralisme
moi je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit ultra
libérale de dépenser 8 milliards d'euros
pour revaloriser les soignants de même
que je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit ultra
libérale de dépenser des centaines de
millions d'euros pour permettre à des
dizaines de milliers d'enfants de partir
en colonie de vacances gratuitement cet
été comme ils sont en train de le faire
sous l'impulsion de jean michel blanquer
alors oui c'est un équilibre que nous
allons poursuivre et nous allons
poursuivre en ce sens vers plus de
justice vers un modèle durable qui fait
que tous les français permettent d'être
embarqué dans la croissance d'être
embarqué dans l'emploi et que tous les
territoires peuvent participer à la
reconstruction du pays c'est comme ça
que nous allons poursuivre pas en
revenant sur des solutions peut-être
satisfaisante et séduisante à court
terme d'augmentation de la fiscalité
mais qui se sont révélées désastreuses à
long terme parce qu'elles ont nui à
l'attractivité du pays parce qu'elles
ont nui à louer l'esprit d'initiative et
à l'esprit d'entreprise dans notre pays
et oui c'est vrai c'est peut-être ce qui
a été fait dans le quinquennat précédent
j étais comme vous et on a vu que ça a
été une très grande réussite
à la fin en tout cas j'assume pleinement
aujourd'hui dessus tout chemin là vers
l'attractivité notre pays et le
développement
la croissance merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur françois
cormier bullygeois monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur jean
michel blanquer ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre
l'émancipation voilà l'objectif de la
république laïque dont nous sommes les
bâtisseurs humble et déterminé faire des
femmes et des hommes des citoyennes et
des citoyens
dès le plus jeune âge par l'instruction
publique
voilà ce à quoi nous travaillons comme
l'a rappelé hier jean castex notre
premier ministre
l'école est là des piliers les plus
importants peut-être même le plus
essentiel de ce projet républicain
c'est bien pourquoi ce grand confinement
a été si pénible en vie dans les classes
de nos écoles de l'énergie et de
l'intelligence qui font vivre au
quotidien
professeurs et élèves heureusement
l'école ne s'est en réalité pas
réellement arrêté et la représentation
nationale salue les professeurs qui ont
continué avec un sens du devoir
exceptionnelle à travailler avec et pour
les enfants de france
nous devons maintenant nous tourner vers
l'avenir
l'une des modalités de la reprise
innovantes des cours a été le dispositif
deux aces de ces mettant à profit le
sport la culture et le stylisme
comme nous vous l'avions suggéré avec
plusieurs de nos collègues dont cédric
roussel et fabienne colboc
trois mille communes se sont engagées
dans ce dispositif pour près de six
mille écoles et près de 170 mille élèves
ce n'est pas si mal pour un dispositif
conçu dans l'urgence pour répondre à une
situation de crise monsieur le ministre
à l'heure où les enfants sont en
vacances les vacances apprenantes
ont-elles vocation à s'inscrire dans
cette dynamique que nous venons
d'évaluer pour l'assemblée nationale
avec ma collègue béatrice descamps à
plus long terme commenté
comment envisagez-vous d'offrir à notre
jeunesse un meilleur accès au sport et à
la culture
avec les enseignants d'abord bien sûr et
avec tout ce qui apporte une solide
pierre à cet édifice et en asie merci
j'ai débuté la parole est à monsieur
jean michel blanquer ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports
merci monsieur le président messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député cormier bouillie l'on
mène sana in corpore sano la fameuse
phrase de juvénal s'applique
complètement aux thèmes que vous venez
d'ouvrir et qui à mes yeux est l'une de
nos très grandes priorités de la rentrée
scolaire et des années suivantes
le fait d'avoir désormais un ministère
de l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
et des sports est évidemment une
opportunité formidable pour aller dans
le sens que vous montrez en effet nous
avons besoin de progresser en france
en réfléchissant davantage sur le temps
de l'élève non seulement dans le temps
scolaire mais dans le temps périscolaire
en ayant pour préoccupation d'arriver à
offrir le sport et la culture davantage
à nos enfants mais entendu la
coopération avec la ministre de la
culture et avec braque sénat maracineanu
qui désormais fait partie de mon équipe
et je m'en réjouis très fortement vont
nous permettre de progresser de manière
très significative
alors vous avez raison de citer les
vacances apprenant parce qu'elles sont
l'illustration
sous nos yeux de ce que nous sommes en
train de dire dans la très grande
tradition de la république et notamment
de ce que jean zay à fait à la fin de la
troisième république
nous sommes en train de renouer avec
cela avec ses vacances à prenantes qui
en ce moment-même permettent à des
enfants défavorisés en particulier mais
à des enfants de tous les milieux
dirt profiter si je puis dire après le
confinement de la nature et de l'accès à
la culture
bien entendu ceci va nous inspirer
maintenant pour développer le dispositif
nous n'allons pas faire deux aces de ces
de la même façon que nous l'avons fait
au mois de juin dans une situation de
crise
nous allons travailler avec les
collectivités locales avec les
associations avec l'ensemble des
partenaires pour tout simplement réussir
à avoir cette vision sur toute la
semaine de ce qui se passe pour l'enfant
cela signifie que dès la rentrée il y
aura des signaux qui seront envoyés en
matière culturelle et en matière
sportive la rentrée en musique est
évidemment le premier de ces signaux
mais cela continuera avec d'autres
projets pour lesquels nous avons déjà
des expérimentations que nous avons
lancé avec la ministre des sports je
pense à vos projets cours le matin sport
l'après midi
mais aussi au plan mercredi et de façon
générale à tous qui permet de voir dans
le temps périscolaire un complément au
temps scolaire je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole à
monsieur jean louis thiériot merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie on
ne peut pas tout attendre de l'état
ce sont vos mots monsieur le premier
ministre nos banques qui portent dans
leur adn les valeurs de la libre
entreprise ne peuvent qu'être d'accord
mais quand c'est nécessaire
l'état doit être le garant de l'intérêt
général
aujourd'hui c'est le grand silence sur
la fermeture programmée de la raffinerie
total de grandpuits en seine-et-marne
ce site qui alimente l'île de france a
subi un incident très grave
avec les fuites du pipeline
d'ile-de-france le pli fô qui ne
fonctionnent qu'à 70% et dont la
modernisation coûterait 300 millions
d'euros
la presse présente la fermeture comme
quasi certaine
sans apporter de réponse précise la
société laisse entendre que le site
pourrait être consacrée aux bioénergies
mais c'est flou c'est gazeux et liquides
ferme et grandpuits représenterait une
triple faute économique stratégique
politique économique car le site emploie
400 personnes et autant d'emplois
indirects stratégique car c'est un
opérateur d'importance vitale pour
l'alimentation de l'ile-de-france
symbolique c'est le général de gaulle en
personne qui a inauguré le site en 66
comme un symbole du nouvel élan
industriel de la france
alors mes questions sont simples que
c'est l'état du projet total pour
grandpuits quelle est votre vision
stratégique du pli fpt
que comptez vous faire pour préserver
l'emploi c'est à l'aune des promesses
d'un monde plus vert que nous partageons
mais aussi des emplois sauvegardés que
vous serez jugés dites nous ce que vous
allez faire pour éviter que ce petit
coin de bris ne rejoigne les cordes
désabusé de la prof france des
périphéries dites nous
concrètement ce que sera l'état stratège
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
madame agnès pannier rina chez ministre
délégué chargé d'industrie j'admire
votre mot merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés mais le député thieriot je vais
pas vous répondre précisément sur votre
question de total je vais investiguer
car très humblement je n'ai pas une
vision complète de la situation mais je
vais vous dire comment nous procédons
sur ce type de situation il faut d'abord
avoir en tête qu'on ne ferme pas comme
ça des sites
c'est une discussion avec les
organisations syndicales au goût qu'elle
nous parle nous prenons notre part au
travers de la délégation
interministérielle restructuration des
entreprises et je veux donner les
chiffres de ré de performance ou de
réalisation de cette délégation puisque
dans ce type de discussion neuf sites
sur dix sont maintenus ouverts et 75 %
des emplois sont également maintenus sur
les sites
voilà les résultats de 2018 et 2019
nous savons tous que nous allons
traverser une crise difficile je ne peux
pas vous donner mes chiffres de 2020
mais c'est bien c'est bien cette c'est
une réalisation que nous souhaitons
avoir comme en feu le faisons nous nous
le faisons en travaillant avec
l'entreprise sont actionnaires ses
dirigeants et les organisations
syndicales pour être sûr de trouver la
meilleure solution possible une solution
dans lequel l'état après à prendre sa
part des l'autre que l'ensemble dès lors
que l'ensemble des autres acteurs se
mettent autour de la table c'est à dire
s'il s'agit d'un projet possible de
fermeture d'aller chercher un repreneur
un repreneur qui puisse soit convertir
le site soit reprendre l'intégralité des
opérations avec
éventuellement des efforts en matière de
passif social et fiscal avec un
accompagnement individualisé des
salariés et avec in fine et une seule
volonté une seule boussole avoir des
projets industriels soutenable conforme
à notre ambition de transition
écologique et qui préserve au maximum
l'emploi
merci madame la ministre la parole d'un
monsieur gabriel serville merci
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de la santé
mais ce le ministre ce week-end vous
avez parcouru 14 mille kilomètres fait
17 heures d'avion pour nous gratifier de
six heures de calino thérapie afin de
redorer le blason des services de l'état
en guyane dont il a été dit qu'elles ont
tous réussi
hélas les chiffres démontrent le
contraire puisque deux mois après le
déconfinement nous sommes passés de 140
à 6300 cas confirmés de convives 19
rapporté à notre population de 300 mille
habitants ce score nous place
malheureusement en tête d'un affligeant
classement mondial et c'est une
véritable honte pour notre république
toutefois je remercie tous les soignants
qui se sont mobilisés aussi bien ceux de
guyenne que ceux de l'hexagone qui ont
répondu à l'appel à la solidarité en
faveur de notre île je dis bien en
faveur de notre île bien ancré dans le
bassin amazonien en amérique du sud plus
grand désert médical de france le chu le
plus proche est située en martinique à
plus de 1500 kilomètres c'est la
distance qui sépare paris de stockholm
et que parcourent chaque année plus de
4000 patients évacué sanitaire
quand ce n'est pas pour se rendre à
paris éloigné de 7000 kilomètres afin
d'être soignées faute de plateaux
techniques adaptées et de spécialistes
sur place
pourtant en juin 2010 est au prix d'une
grève de soixante quatorze jours le
personnel de l'hôpital de cayenne
obtenait l'engagement d'une
transformation de l'établissement en chu
un chu mort-né et enterrée par votre
prédécesseur avec une parfaite
clairvoyance dont on peut apprécier
aujourd'hui les conséquences
monsieur le ministre la guyane ne
quémande pas et n'a jamais sollicité le
j'ai acheté qui lui a été imposée et
puisque cayenne est aussi française que
la mayenne nous demandons seulement à
être autrement jeu
si bien à être autrement accompagner
pour qu'en matière de santé ce ne soit
pas encore la rue qui arrache une
décision tant de fois reportée
comme ce fut le cas pour l'académie ou
encore pour l'université de plein
exercice
aussi quelle suite comptez vous accordez
à la motion unitaire qui vous a été
remise le 12 juillet mais par les forces
vives du territoire
merci monsieur le député la parole comme
monsieur olivier ferrand ministre des
solidarités et de la santé monsieur le
député gabriel serville effectivement
nous sommes rencontrés lors du
déplacement du premier ministre à
cayenne dimanche dernier un déplacement
vous n'avez pas suivi la totalité vous
étiez à la préfecture avec les élus pour
je vous ai vus autour du pot que nous
avons prié convivial et vous étiez la
dernière étape
vous n'avez était pas vous ne deviez pas
vais pouvoir à la visite hospitalière
monsieur normes attendait faut dire les
choses à mort des ça suffit
n'étiez pas avec nous monsieur le député
servile lors de la visite de l'hôpital
sans quoi vous pourriez rencontrer
l'équipe de réanimation et l'équipe de
réanimation ne nous a dit que nous a dit
une chose très forte sur ce service chez
pirelli nation nous a dit nous n'avons
jamais manquer de lits nous n'avons même
jamais manqué de respirateurs nous
n'avons jamais manqué de place pour
ensuite alizés les malades et sauver des
vies monsieur n'avons jamais manqué de
matériel de protection nous sommes très
fiers de l'action était menée
déterminante pour sauver des vies en
guyane et ça c'est une réalité et soyez
fiers de cela mais ce député
soyez fiers de l'action déterminée est
déterminante
monsieur monsieur le député nous avons
rencontré aussi les autres élus de la
collectivité et vous nous avez remis
ainsi que par exemple monsieur rodolphe
alexandre et d'autres élus de la guyane
une demande portant sur le chu et je
vais vous répondre sur cette question en
particulier le premier ministre a eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur ce sujet en
disant qu'il était déterminé à renforcer
davantage les liens entre le système
sanitaire et la recherche sur la guyane
il y à l'heure à laquelle je vous parle
neuf pays ph à dire neuf professeurs de
médecine alors qu'il n'y en avait que de
mémoire vous me direz que je me trompe 3
il y as au début de quinquennat les
choses se renforce d'avoir visité
également monsieur le député avec le
premier ministre institut pasteur qui
montrent que l'excellence de la
recherche en santé en guyane encore une
fois des choses incroyables
la guyane est le département français
qui a eu bénéficiait lui plus de tests
de tous les départements français depuis
le début de l'épidémie
et c'est ce qui a permis avec
l'excellence de la médecine et la
détermination des soignants de sauver
des vies et d'enrayer l'épidémie à
l'heure à laquelle je vous parle les
indicateurs sont plutôt rassurants par
rapport à la semaine dernière
encore une fois c'est l'intérêt général
monsieur servi l'on ne doit pas obliger
de s'envoyer des trucs au visage quand
on parle de la santé les français et en
particulier des guyanais merci monsieur
le ministre la parole est à madame
sophie par l'onac
merci monsieur le président j'associe à
la question tous mes collègues de la
team maritime
madame la ministre de la mer le
président de la république vient de vous
confier une mission à vrai dire une
réelle ambition celle de porter la
politique maritime de la france celle
d'engager l'accélération de notre
stratégie maritime avec le gouvernement
de jean castex notre nouveau premier
ministre
le retour de ministère de la mer de
plein exercice met fin à trois décennies
d'absence qui ont affaibli notre rang de
deuxième puissance océanique mondial
après avoir depuis trois ans avec mes
collègues de la team soutenu la
communauté maritime dans toutes ses
composantes
je sais que la tante des gens de mer
était devenu particulièrement forte et
de façon encore plus pressante
face à la crise sanitaire madame la
ministre de la mer la tâche est immense
les enjeux le sont aussi
c'est pourquoi il est indispensable que
l'étendue de vos compétences en lien
avec la mer et le littoral soit vaste
c'est pourquoi il est nécessaire que
votre ministère soit dotée de moyens à
la hauteur de la mission qui vous est
confiée
car désormais il s'agit de tracer de
nouvelles voies qui préserve nos océans
et contribuent au développement
harmonieux de l'économie bleus sur
l'hexagone et les territoires
ultramarins
pour cela nous avons besoin d'une
économie compétitive et décarbonées pour
les activités portuaires les transports
les industries navales et nautiques la
pêche l'aquaculture et les umr d'un
dialogue social améliorant les
conditions de travail et permettant la
création de nouveaux emplois d'un
engagement écologique fil conducteur est
fédérateur pour protéger le milieu marin
et sa biodiversité d'un investissement
scientifiques afin de ceux de conforter
notre politique maritime en l'étayant
sur une connaissance solide d'une
politique éducative et pédagogique qui
doit donner envie de mer à notre
jeunesse d'une ambition diplomatique
pour porter haut le pavillon français
dans les négociations européennes et
internationales
madame la ministre de la mer pouvez vous
nous donner le cap du navire france afin
que le 21e siècle soit définitivement
maritime je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole comme
madame annick girardin ministre de la
mer monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires madame la
députée fans au nac
alors oui après une absence de 30 ans le
ministère de la mer est à nouveau créé
il s'est félicité et s'est félicité par
tous par tous par les quatre cent mille
français qui travaillent dans le domaine
de la mer ou dans des activités qui sont
liées à la mer par les 975 communes
françaises du littoral qu'elle soit dans
les territoires d'outre-mer ou dans
l'hexagone par les associations
impliquées sur les questions
effectivement littoral ou ou maritime
par les usagers eux mêmes
et puis je suis extrêmement fier
effectivement madame la députée de créer
ce ministère à la demande du premier
ministre et du président de la
république bien sûr parce que quelque
part la mère fait partie de mon adn
je suis une malouine qui a toujours vécu
outre-mer à saint-pierre et miquelon
pays de marins j'ai été parlementaire et
j'ai été souvent ici comme d'autres
comme vous comme toute votre équipe de
la team maritime la voix de la mère sur
ses bons et je sais d'ailleurs que cette
voie maritime elle est sur l'ensemble
l'ensemble des bons alors président de
la république l'avait annoncé aux
assises de l'économie maritime l'an
dernier il avait souhaité que ce
ministère soient créés et le premier
ministre bien sûr l'a clairement annoncé
réaffirmant une stratégie maritime clair
une stratégie maritime
bien sûr mais surtout un portage
politique unifiée et cette politique
bien sûr elle est définie dans dans le
décret qui sera publié dans les dents
les quelques jours et oui elle va parler
bien entendu de tout ce qui est
important pour la mère de
l'environnement de la pêche du transport
maritime de la formation d énergie
ou lab de la recherche mais cette
mission je la ferai qu'avec l'ensemble
des ministres qui sont ici et qui
participeront à cette ambition forte que
le président de la république et le
premier ministre nous a demandé de faire
et ça a toujours été ma méthode la co
construction et le partage dans ses
politiques maritimes pour les français
pour la france mais aussi que nous
puissions porter cette ambition au
niveau européen au niveau international
aux nations unies et que la voix de la
mère six mois mais par ceux des
initiatives beaucoup plus forte
merci ma minute la parole à madame
sylvie tout le monde madame la ministre
de l'enseignement supérieur de la
recherche et de l'innovation
hier le premier ministre annonçait le
repas à 1 euro pour les étudiants
boursiers
encore faudra-t-il pour y accéder
pouvoir s'inscrire à l'université en
effet comme vous l'exprimez valérie
rabault à l'unisson des présidents
d'université nous sommes très inquiètes
quant aux possibilités d'accueillir dans
des conditions sanitaires acceptables
les 35 mille étudiants supplémentaires
attendus à la rentrée prochaine
face à cet afflux est bien que les
dispositifs oui si prévu par la loi aux
erreurs devraient être proposés un plus
grand nombre d'étudiants les capacités
d'accueil des établissements resteront
limités sans compter les problématiques
de locaux insuffisant et de ressources
humaines disponibles il y a un vrai
risque à ce que ces étudiants ne
puissent trouver des offres de
formations adaptées à leurs projets
individuels
vous proposez 1600 euros aux universités
pour chaque étudiant supplémentaire
quand le coût complet d'un an de
scolarité scolarité pardon s'établit
entre 10000 et 16000 euros selon les
filières
c'est largement insuffisant aider
véritablement la jeunesse implique
d'affecter immédiatement les moyens
nécessaires pour cette rentrée 2009 a
estimé à 300 millions d'euros par les
présidents d'université
nous vous les avons proposé dans votre
dans notre plan de rebond et lors du
père fr3 vous les avez refusé vouloir
lutter réellement contre l'aggravation
la précarité des étudiants c'est
également prolongé les bourses d'un an
et répondre à la situation des étudiants
impacté par la perte de leurs revenus en
raison de la crise
nous vous appelons à une refonte des
aides sociales
afin de les adapter à la réalité de la
vie étudiante madame la ministre vous
promettez dans la future loi dit-elle
pprd milliards d'euros à la recherche
sur les dix prochaines années sans
offrir les millions aujourd'hui demandé
à l'enseignement universitaire alors au
delà du gel des droits d'inscription
dans le supérieur quelles sont vos
propositions concrètes pour répondre à
cette urgence et permettent l'accueil de
tous les étudiants dans le respect des
règles sanitaires
merci chers collègues la parole et
avocat me frédéric vidal ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
et de l'innovation
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés mes amis députés
cdh lit tellement tout d'abord vous dire
à quel point les universités dans ces
mois difficiles ont été en capacité et
ont prouvé une fois de plus ce qu'elle
était en capacité de relever des défis
incroyables comme continuer à
accompagner l'ensemble des étudiants par
des formations à distance des formations
numérique et puis leurs capacités aussi
à faire en sorte que leur année soit
validé plusieurs mesures qui sont là
pour accompagner l'ensemble des jeunes
c'est une promesse du premier ministre
une promesse du président de la
république
une promesse de ma part nous trouverons
des solutions pour chacun de ces jeunes
d'abord nous avons vu la robustesse de
parcours sud nous n'avons pas découvert
ses nouveaux bacheliers l'ensemble des
étudiants des élèves inscrits en
terminale étaient sur la plate forme et
donc nous avons pu anticiper anticipé en
créant des places dans des bts anticipé
en créant des années dites de type paréo
de type ou ici même si 35 mille élèves
ne sont pas apparus nous les avions sur
parcours sup sommes en train
d'accompagner 10000 de manière
individuelle nous les avons appelés un
par an et notre objectif c'est bien
qu'il y ait des places à la rentrée pour
tout le monde des places dans des
filières qui sont extrêmement demandés
là encore nous avons vu l'engagement de
notre jeunesse pendant cette crise avec
des demandes très forte sur des filières
sanitaires et sociales sur des filières
paramédicales qui sont sous la
responsabilité des régions eh bien nous
allons aider les régions à ouvrir plus
place donc oui nous accueillerons
l'ensemble de ses étudiants et au moment
où nous nous parlons ils sont
accompagnés un par un par l'ensemble des
services du ministère et puis des
mesures de rentrer des mesures fortes
qui ont été annoncées par le premier
ministre diviser par trois le prix d'un
repas équilibré dans un restaurant
universitaire c'est inédit ça ne s'est
jamais vu pour la deuxième année
consécutive nous allons geler les droits
d'inscription et nous préparons d'autres
mesures car notre jeunesse et notre
avenir je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement et terminer la
séance est suspendue